I just want to be GM, right? But he says he wants to be in like
the OWCS and it's like he's clearly can't put the effort in to
do it. So he just sounds
Bro, God is this guy. What did this guy Dude, you're devout.
How How do you get over that where like everything is going wrong?
What are these challenges?
Why? What? I don't know why you would do that. That's not a Nazi
salute, but why the are you doing that, bro? It's that podcast
where he wanted to speak openly about uncomfortable topics. Uhoh.
For the love of God on this aim map, start flicking. I want to
see his flick. Let's see the flicks, bro. Show me your
I want to watch Game for Hope now. I'm going to watch Game for
Hope. Sorry, we didn't we didn't catch up on this.
>> I remember everything.
>> This guy, Kelly, is this guy. I've not seen any of this,
by the way. I've seen 0 minutes 0 seconds of Game of Hope content.
I've had it minorly explained to me. This guy's basically like
a like a 35. He's like midlife crisis guy who decided he was
gonna be professional in Overwatch, but he sucks. He is like
terrible.
Um,
and he did like a video a while back saying like, "Oh, my complete
road map to competing in the Overwatch Championship Series or
something." OWCS basically like, "Oh, I'm gonna become like a
pro Overwatch player. I'm gonna make it going on 50." He's like
26 years old going on 50. Oh, sorry. So, he's he's pushing 30.
Okay, pushing 30, trying to be a pro gamer. That's way too late.
All right, that's too late. Maybe if you were a giga pro gamer
in your earlier age, you could like stay pro at 26. You're never
going to become pro at 26. It's never happening. Okay.
>> All right. I need to hit play on this and get some more
water. But I'm going to watch this. We're going to watch this.
We're going to catch up. I am very excited. Okay. Oh, you know
what? I'm actually not. Kelly, >> is this I feel like this
is bullying. Oh, it's giga bullying. It's giga like this guy
self-reporting that his life sucks. It's going to be very funny.
Okay, but I need you to babysit chat for 2 minutes so I can use
the bathroom. Get wired. I'll be right back. >> Sure, why
not? >> Cuz I I actually don't want to skip any of this.
I want to be here for all of it. So, give me a second. >> You
are very excited about
mentally delayed people. Okay.
>> He has three kids and a wife. Well, there's hope for
the rest of you then. >> my excitement over mentally delayed
people is also mirrored in my pirate software coverage, which
is why I love covering that guy.
>> I don't think that has anything to do with mental illness,
does it? It just has to do with the fact that he's uppety
>> and doesn't like apologizing.
This guy seems like he might be developmentally
>> Seems a little bit different.
Nah, he's just sudden.
>> You haven't even heard him speak. Do I need to? I can
see him. He's got a microphone attached to a spatula. I don't
I don't know why you're so negative to me, but I'm not the one
that's like demonstrated like a lack of cognitive ability. Okay.
>> How can a guy also have a wife and three kids? Um, I
guess he's just got a better personality than the rest of you.
I don't know. You just had to uh suck less than everyone else.
>> Bro, imagine trying to take a and everybody here is
like, "Why are you calling this guy?" And Kelly's like, "He's
got a microphone attached to a spatula." I'm looking at him.
I I died. Holy sh >> He has a microphone attached to his
spatula right now. >> Is that No. what it is. >> That
is literally what it is. Yes. >> Okay.
Yes, >> dude. What the [__] Okay. Anyway. Okay.
Gaming for Hope. I've done all the intera all the introduction
I need to do. I think this is his first big video was this one.
Okay. He at the ripe age of 26 or whatever is going to try to
make it as a pro gamer. >> I want to compete at the highest
levels of Overwatch in the Overwatch Champions Series, but there's
a problem. I'm 28 years old, married, and raising a family. This
makes the path to get there much longer and consequently more
challenging. I have >> Yeah, like consequently impossible
and something that would be irresponsible to engage in when you
have a [__] >> Created a detailed road map
to accomplish my goal despite the additional challenges. I even
have a timeline to go along with it that I'm happy to share with
you at the end. And I know what you're thinking. Anyone can compete
in the OWCS. I know I could just jump in, but I don't think I
should just jump in. I mean, if all I ever wanted to do was check
the box to say that I competed, I would do that. >> Your
scientists were so preoccupied with whether or not they could,
they didn't stop to think they should. >> At the start
of my journey in May of 2023, my dream >> uh man, May of
2023, and this is October 2024,
so year and five months.
Trying to think if like if a year or two into playing a video
game, if you don't know if you could be pro in that video game,
I don't know. I don't think that's where you like make your decision,
you should have a pretty good indication.
I think >> was to compete in the Overwatch League. The
Overwatch League itself seemed incredibly exciting to me, but
at the time there really wasn't a clear path on how to get in.
And then, seemingly out of nowhere, the league itself came to
a complete and abrupt end. And if we're being honest, the moment
that made boys cry was Obi-Wan and Anakin's epic duel in Star
Wars Episode 3. But the moment that made men shed tears was when
Zoe delivered that heartfelt speech, marking the end of the Overwatch
League. But from the ashes of the League, the Overwatch Champions
Series emerged. I mean, whether you love it or hate it, the route
to get into the OWCS is very clear and very simple. However,
simply participating in the Overwatch Champion Series wasn't
enough for me. My new goal quickly became to place in the top
50 teams of the competition. Since then, I've experimented with
various strategies and approaches. Honestly,
>> I All I need to know at this point, you've played for
a year. Just show me your rank. If you're not if you're literally
not in like Grandmaster at this point, it's I'm sorry. It's literally
not >> I didn't even have a clear direction until I started
making this video. Now I finally have a solid plan in place right
>> Okay. He didn't have a solid plan before. That's why
he's not been successful. He now has a solid plan in place. He
will be successful. I got it. I got it. >> I find myself
feeling stuck in what many referred to as Elo Hell, otherwise
known as platinum.
>> Doesn't exist. Elo Hell. Okay, he's plaid. At least
I thought he was going to be like bronze. At least he's plat.
Ilo hell doesn't exist. You suck. That is that is all it is.
You suck. Everybody who's ever been good at games knows ELO hell
does not exist. You suck. Stop blaming it on everyone else. >> Let's
be honest, the gap between a platinum player and the top 50 teams
of the OWCS feels like not just one Grand Canyon, but at least
four. While your public rank may not be the most precise measurement
of your skills, >> it is. It's always an incredibly accurate
measurement of your skills unless you haven't played in years.
If you play regularly, if you play a couple times a day, a couple
matches a day, it is an incredibly accurate, perfectly accurate
measurement of your skills. And based on how long you've been
playing the game, could be an actual accurate measurement of
your possible talent or aptitude. It definitely serves as a great
indicator of your ability as a solo player. As a result, my first
major goal on this journey is to elevate myself to the level
of a master's tank player. Achieving this involves a variety
of strategies and a lot of dedicated effort. Primarily, it means
identifying areas where I am falling short and taking steps to
improve in those areas. I sometimes find success by conducting
selfod reviews, but I've also discovered that getting feedback
from a qualified coach can be even more beneficial. No matter
the you need a coach to get better at these games, you again
uh all you should need. Okay, maybe Dota it helped. Dota I used
to watch um you could watch videos on Dota and they would just
give you like builds and stuff. It was like helpful. There's
like some helpful stuff there. I don't see how it could possibly
be helpful in Overwatch. Maybe like some little tips and tricks,
but like ultimately aim is aim and like understanding is >> method.
I focus on pinpointing one specific aspect of my gameplay that
when improved will lead to significant progress. During my ranked
matches, I concentrate solely on that particular aspect. I try
not to dwell on whether I won or lost or even who was to blame
for the result. instead. >> That is literally key to improving
it at all team games. Yes. Oh, okay. That's awesome.
That's awesome. He uh he gets it. Okay, he gets it. Yes. Focus
on the things you need to improve. Focus on getting better at
like one thing at a time. And literally, wins and losses do not
matter at all. Wins and wins and losses can't matter. If you
want to get better at a game, winning or losing at ranked is
the last thing you care about. And everybody else, you need to
be in a zen place cuz everybody else who's upset, those people.
I'm doing this for >> I focus on whether or not I actually
made improvements in that area. I chose to isolate as an individual
player. Improving as an individual player is just one man. Imagine
being one of his kids and discovering this video and realizing
he like missed a soccer practice or a soccer game because he
needed to play Overwatch. How up would that be? You like discover
this video like 5 10 years from now. It's your dad explaining
why he wasn't at your ballerina or ballet recital or whatever
>> Not great. Not great. Could you imagine being such a
loser that you'd play video games over taking care of your kids?
>> My overall goal of being able to place in the top 50
teams in the OWCS. At the highest levels of play, Overwatch 2
truly becomes a team focused game. Success requires not only
excellent individual skills, but also strong teamwork that matches
or even exceeds those skills. In the past, when I was focused
on my Overwatch League journey, the goal was to utilize the social
media following that I have to attract teams in the contenders
area and network my way up from there. However, I have since
discovered the next vital step,
in scrims for >> Oh, he is. >> Those who might not
know, scrims are practice sessions specifically designed for
honing team play. Personally, I plan to form a team of like-minded
individuals who are eager to compete alongside me as we strive
together to compete in the OWCS. So far, I feel like I've made
pretty good progress in this area. I mean, we even scrimmed together
for a while under the team nameopium. However, we recently recognized
that >> game it foropium gaming for hope. Let's >> Need
to bring our individual >> need to watch his scrim plays.
I happen to have within my thing here
a pro
>> VOD review. Now, I assume this would be Scrims, right?
I assume this would be Scrims, but I don't know for sure. And
I've got this guy reviewing it. All right. Pro Overwatch players
spectator.
>> Is that anyone plays Overwatch or cares about that anymore?
Like, who? >> Yeah. It's a weird thing. Just remember,
he's got kids. He's got kids. He's got kids. You literally got
kids, Kelly. Not >> UAL skill ratings more closely together
to enhance our overall performance. By focusing on teamwork in
these scrims, we can develop better communication and coordination,
which are essential for success in highstakes competitions. My
goal is to create an environment where each member, >> By
the way, uh scrimming at this level is not really that that helpful,
that consequential. Um, when you're bad enough at the game, scrimming
is probably just a waste of your time. Scrimming will make you
try to learn to communicate. It'll it'll divert your Exactly
as we said in pubs. You need to go and work on like one thing.
Have a thing you're working on, get better at it. Right. That's
what you need to do. If you are scrimming while you suck at >> your
highest elo just to call
>> uh I was I think a top five Winston in the first two
seasons. Uh top five, top 10 in North America. I was like >> How many
years ago was that? >> We play it was at the start of the
game. first two seasons. >> No, but no one was playing
it. >> I played GM and Masters.
>> Yeah, I was I had a rank number. Show proof. I could
easily I'm not going to cuz I think it uh I think it's like attached
to Hold on. No, no, no. I think it's attached to like personal
information, right? But I could go and like I could go see if
I could change my account over to like some other email and
and I can show you the sprays. I have the sprays from the first
two season Yeah. first two seasons I played against all the people
who were really good. Played against Poke all the time. Played
against XQC all the time,
right? I played against well, sorry, the gamer, the like streamer
types, I guess. I think I told this story that I played against
Moon a couple times and I totally dominated Moon in a game and
then I started typing in all chat about how like I would kill
myself if I was this bad at the game and played professionally
like he did. I I was talking so much after I totally outplayed
him. I think Reinhardt v Reinhardt. I like wiped his whole team
cuz he got fooled by a juke and [__] and I was talking
so much and then I went to watch his his VOD to see if um I went
to watch his VOD to see like how he was taking it and he had
chat shut off and he just didn't respond and he was like oh that
man that guy totally owned me. That guy's so good. I was like
god damn it. I like was telling this guy to kill himself but
he's like this guy is so good. Holy [__] man. That
guy destroyed me. I was like oh now I feel really bad. I feel
really everyone clapped, bro. Moon was not a pro player. Moon
was just a streamer. He He I think he had a high rank for a while,
but he was not a pro player or anything. Now, now it's like,
oh, it was Moon. It wasn't even I thought Moon was really good
cuz he had a high rank anyway. Yeah, I actually had a high elo
in this game. You could have picked anything else, Kelly, but
I actually had a high elo in this game. >> can grow together,
ultimately pushing us >> said, "Why am I banned from chat?
I'm going to hear you myself." Um, >> is she back? >> She
comes in here and self-promos for no
>> Can we unfree her? >> I She is unfree currently.
>> Oh,
okay.
>> Top 50 spot. My biggest challenge, though, goes well
beyond Overwatch, and that's actually the area of my finances
right now.
Oh no. Oh no. Oh no.
I don't you get it, guys? Kelly said, "Can we unfree her?" And
I was like, she is unfree right now. What is the opposite of
free? >> That's just annoying. That's not even
>> I learned it from my I learned it from Smug Bug, my
favorite content creator, Smug Bug, >> ultimately pushing
us all toward that top 15 spot. My biggest challenge, though,
goes well beyond Overwatch. And that's actually the area of my
finances. Right now, I can't afford to drop to part-time work
and support my family.
>> Bro, no.
No, no.
>> At the start of this journey, I was actually a full-time
content creator. I was fortunate enough to be in that situation
because of some very supportive family members and driving for
Uber and Lift part-time. However,
I'm in psychic pain. Kelly. Kelly. I'm in psychic pain.
Kelly. Oh, wait. I will >> How do you find these people?
This is the most >> What's Lamb's name? Lab's name. Is
it fairy foid? I am banned fairy. Yeah, >> it felt like
everything changed overnight when our emergency fund ran out.
Leave >> I I'll unban her from chat. She's fine in chat.
Anyway, dude.
Oh, the idea that he's like, "Dude, I thanks to supportive supportive
family members." He's literally getting his parents or some to
pay for him to play video games while they like pay for his family.
Brother
>> We can't do anything. Can we at least make sure there's
no more kids? Can we make sure there are no more additional kids
involved, please? I understand there are kids already and we
will accept that, but no more kids, please. >> Leaving
us in a really tough financial situation. And that's when I realized
I had to put my family first and step back from being a full-time
creator. The struggle became very real in >> Wait, what?
Brother, this is not a sustainable schedule in any possible way.
What are we doing here?
Uh, this is literally an impossible completely completely impossible
schedule to maintain. There's a 0% chance he could maintain the
schedule. If he maintained the schedule or was even close to
it, he would not be that. Okay, that's just facts. This is this
is an impossible schedule.
This is crazy. This is crazy work. Okay.
>> My god. 5:45 a.m.
until
10:30 to 11:00 p.m. 10:30 p.m. each >> And that as >> that's
why he's going pro. Do we notice a problem here that we have
one hour of Overwatch competitive per day? Oh, sorry. He takes
a day off. Okay. Now, for for like 16-year-olds, all right, for
16-year-olds who are brand new to video games and have like the
like un un uh what you call like um dulled neurons, they can
form neuronal connections correctly. And for those people, maybe
if they had this schedule right here, they could go pro and Overwatch.
Okay, maybe. Maybe he's inverted it. Okay, you would need to
play your your work schedule would need to be your playing schedule.
He's not even close to trying at this. I don't know why has nobody
pointed this out to him that it's literally impossible with this
much time put into the game. Like, you have a family, you're
taking care of your family, you're working full-time. That's
cool, right? That's neat, but you're literally not it's not possible
to go and become a pro from this. >> As of then, I could
only dedicate about 10 hours a week to playing Overwatch. So,
my wife and I created a financial plan to give ourselves a year-long
runway of sorts. First, we'll focus on paying off our debts.
>> Damn, this woman is a keeper.
If he manages to keep her after this, damn. >> I don't
understand. But the good thing about this, Kelly, is it is basically
10 months ago. Okay. So, we actually can start learning where
this story goes over time, which fortunately consists of just
a couple of car loans and some credit card bills. Once that's
sorted, we'll build an emergency fund that can cover a full year
of our expenses. After we accomplish these goals, I plan to quit
my teller job and use that extra time to focus on creating content
and improving my skills as an Overwatch competitor. Ultimately,
all the extra time that I gained by
before they even get the money to be able to sustain this >> seems
to be the case.
seems >> by the time this guy can afford to be an Overwatch
pro, the Overwatch will not >> Yeah. No, he's uh I don't
know why he's not going Well, I do know why he's not going for
Valerant. Valerant probably wasn't working out for him, unfortunately,
but >> make much sense. If I don't use it wisely. That's
where the next important step comes into play. Competing in smaller
tournaments. With Face It now being natively part of Overwatch
2, organizing structured tournaments has become easier than ever
before. A fantastic way of putting those skills to the test is
by jumping into tournaments. This not only gives us the chance.
>> This would be true. Yeah, I'm guessing he's getting
knocked out before the tournaments get anywhere >> to compete,
but also allows us to potentially earn some cash prizes. >> Hello,
I like money. >> By combining this tournament experience
with the additional content I'm
>> hold on. Let's let me look at the Patreon for Game of
Hope. $235 a month. It's not good. It's not good. Life is difficult.
Don't do it alone. Oh boy.
>> I can support my family better. Plus, this could help
my team gain some social media attention and attract potential
sponsors. I mean, in a perfect world, this opportunity would
open the teammates doors to leaving their 9to- fives if they
so chose. You see, it's very important to me that as I grow and
succeed that I am not the only one reaping the benefits. Even
after accomplishing all >> dude this is this is psychotic
a little bit right as I grow and succeed I don't how how appreciient
is this by the way that he is literally speaking into a spatula
when the most likely career path for him is like McDonald's it's
it feels weird it feels okay >> see that I am not the only
one reaping the benefits even after accomplishing all of these
steps I truly believe there's one more important thing I can
do at this point. I can only imagine that I'll be working hard
to reach Grandmaster as a player. If I'm not already at that
level, I will focus on closing the gap in order to get there.
However, simply reaching Grandmaster rank isn't the end goal
I have in mind here. My real aim is to be among the top 25 tanks
in the North American region. This might not seem like that big
of a deal when it comes to the OWCS, but it does I think I got
close to this, by the way. I think I did actually get somewhat
close to this.
I want to say I got close to top 100ish.
I I think I got to double digit rank in the top 500. And I think
as a tank, if you're in double digit ranks,
I think you would be one of the top 25 tanks cuz most of the
top 100 would be DPS, right? >> Were you doing anything
else the rest of your life at this point?
>> Uh getting my degree, I think. No, working my first
job. No, getting my degree. Both. >> You don't remember?
it would have gone well I don't remember I don't remember exactly
what years it was I think it was my first job >> out of
that >> I will say absolutely true yes absolutely true
cuz I think I think I was playing Overwatch I think I still had
a Dota rank that was fairly high as well I think it was pretty
I was playing a lot of games okay I think it was my first job
I think I had my first job at this point >> means something
very important to me by striving for this goal I can >> yeah
see what I was able to accomplish I was able to accomplish great
things in multiple realms through virtue of not trying to have.
Okay, what a novel >> Build even more self-confidence in
my abilities as a player. It's not just about the rank. It's
about knowing that I can compete at a high level. And
>> uh crime boss rock a city, if you could find this stuff,
I can't find this stuff anymore. If somebody else could find
this stuff, I would just love to have like proof beyond just
my ranks that are on my my sprays or whatever. I don't think
my rank is even on the sprays besides just the sprays. You can
find this stuff. It'd be cool. >> Be among the best. I
would hope to complete everything I need to do in less than a
year so I can be ready to compete in 2025.
>> Oh, also mained Winston
uh secondary Zarya and Reinhardt. And then I also made top 500
in season 2 maining support with Anna. That's what it is. I thought
it was pretty cool to main Anna only and make it top 500 as well.
Okay. I thought that was pretty I think that was pretty baller.
I got a second account, just spammed Anna, made top 500 again.
I thought that was pretty cool. Favorite meta? Um I quit like
right as the triple tank was coming out and I was like this is
garbage. This is such garbage. >> However, it's crucial
to understand the difference between what I hope for and what
is actually possible. In truth, competing in >> Wait, wait,
wait. Hold on. This whole video is going to make sense.
what is possible versus
what I can sorry what I want versus what is actually possible.
We'll finally get the the splash of cold water. Okay. 2025 may
not allow me to reach my ultimate goal of being in the top 50
teams. On the other hand, competing in 20. >> No, if you
were in the top 25 tanks, I think you could be in the top 50
teams very easily. I think you absolutely would, but he's not
going to make it to the top 25 tanks. >> T6 is still a
big challenge, but it feels much more achievable. I didn't begin
this journey because I was afraid of facing obstacles. So yes,
competing in the OWCS in the year 2026 is my uh ultimate timeline
and is the timeline that I promised I would share with you. While
this road map and time,
>> no, don't give us 2026 >> to accomplish it are
clear, an additional challenge I had to overcome was making the
time to walk down this path. See what I did there? In this video
right here, I share some surprising sacrifices I had to make
in order to make that time. Uh, yes please. Yes, please. I did
not have that video.
>> I did not have that video and now I have that video.
I did not have that video before. I have it now. Thank [__]
for this guy. Okay, this is going to be >> Including the
Overwatch Champion series. It will require you to make sacrifice.
>> What did he sacrifice, Kelly? What do you sacrifice?
>> Okay, give me two seconds. I'm going to go grab >> I
sacrifice
>> watching something good instead of what this is. >> Whoops.
Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Whoops. Hold on. I just something up.
I just moved it up. God damn it. Give me >> What do you
sacrifice? >> Calm, kindness, kinship, love. I've given
up all chance at inner peace. I made my mind a sunless base.
I share my dreams with ghosts. I wake up every day to an equation
I wrote 15 years ago from which there's only one conclusion.
I'm damned for what I do. My anger, my ego, my unwillingness
to yield, my my eagerness to fight has set me on a path from
which there's no escape. I yearn to be a savior against injustice
without contemplating the cost. And by the time I look down,
there's no longer any ground beneath my feet. What is my What
is my sacrifice? I'm condemned to use the tools of my enemy to
defeat them. I burn my decency for someone else's future. I burn
my life to make a sunrise that I know I'll never see. The ego
that started this fight will never have a a mirror or an audience
or the light of gratitude. So, what do I sacrifice? Everything.
Man, that monologue is so cool. And it's so much less cool, unfortunately,
with Kelly's face on it. But it it's just so accurate for Kelly.
>> then why not play the original? >> Cuz it's funny.
It's so accurate for your face.
>> That's the unfortunate thing. >> I don't know
what the context of that >> I don't know. I just like the
the monologue in the show. >> Your thoughts on Andor season
2, by the way? I didn't like it. >> What was the context
as to why someone made that? I can't remember what it was. I
think I watched the monologue on stream and then said it was
like you. Crazy that Molina is dating that guy's son now. True.
>> Yeah, obviously. I'm trying to remember the context
of why. I forget. >> I think I was just talking about how
I really like that monologue. How it was just a really good monologue.
But
>> And see what
my enemy part, isn't it? >> No, it's because of it's I
can literally hold on.
chance at inner peace. I made my mind a sunless face. >> It's
like this one. Hold on. It's
>> like I'm doomed to use the tools of my enemy or something
>> up all chance at inner sunless >> related to that
>> my dreams with ghosts. >> Hold on. Hold on. >> From
which there's only one conclusion. I'm dead. My my eager anger
my ego my unwillingness to yield. My my eagerness to fight. >> Yeah,
that's the part that's the part that I'm like thinking of precisely.
Anger, ego, unwillingness to yield, my willingness to fight.
Yeah, I check check check.
That's not why this got made. It's because of the using of the
tools of the enemy thing. I would not be surprised if it was
like the hemorrhoids where I started attacking Lena. >> Probably
actually true. But
>> we wait to talk about that until I was eating. That's
awesome. >> Or something. As if you care. >> It's
fine. I don't. All right. Game for Hope. A day in the life of
an aspiring OWCS competitor. What did he sacrifice, guys? What
did he sacrifice to make it? What did he sacrifice out of his
kids' lives? Okay. My kids don't get rain boots so that I can
pay my Overwatch coach double what I was paying last season.
Okay, sacrifices have to be >> Sometimes many of them.
Competing at the highest level of Overwatch is not just a matter
of continuing to queue up in ranked and consequently is no exception
to this rule. The biggest challenge we face when pursuing anything
at a high level in life is how to best use our time. We all have
the same 168 hours in the week. And in order for me to succeed
at everything that's on my plate, my schedule's packed. Between
family commitments, my full-time job, being a content creator,
and more recently adding a focus into competing at the highest
levels of Overwatch 2, managing my time has become an essential
juggling act. In order to make sure I didn't cut out anything
that's important to me, I started by being intentional about
writing my priorities out to make them clear. Personally, my
highest priority in my life is my faith in Christ. My faith anchors
me into a very clear reason as to why I do >> Sorry, you
lost. There's a whole bunch of players in the Overwatch League
whose top priority in their life is Overwatch.
That's probably the key ingredient to making it into Overwatch
League or the Champion Series or whatever the number one priority
Overwatch. Sorry.
Do everything that I do in my life. Apart from Christianity,
succeeding in anything in life would feel relatively pointless
to me. Right underneath my relationship with Christ is my relationship
with my wife. She is truly the most amazing.
You can have once you get wins, okay? Once you hit GM, that's
when you can have until then you grind. You don't [__]
your wife until you're >> literally just told us. >> I
just told That's literally what I said. Yeah, I said I was grinding
up,
>> Obviously, everybody wanted to [__] once
I got there. No, obviously I got once I got there. >> He's
saying, >> "How fat were you at that moment?" >> Are
you serious right now? Stop. Very rude. Very rude. a couple,
we have chosen to live a very traditional lifestyle. But please
don't get the wrong picture in your head. Succeeding in bringing
up a family requires teamwork. And that sometimes means I'm washing
the dishes, changing a diaper, or hanging out with my children
while she folds and puts away the laundry. Trust me, she'd never
want me to do that because evidently I do it all wrong. My third
highest priority.
>> Sorry, I'll control myself.
>> priority in my life is my children. According to the
National Fatherhood Initiative, nearly 1 in four children in
the United States alone don't have a father figure. These poor
kiddos are more likely to wind up in prison, drop out of high
school, abuse drugs, and many other things. The way I see it,
without my active engagement in my kids' lives, I'm just contributing
to this problem. The first sacrifice I had to make in order to
start aligning with these priorities was being a full-time content
creator. Even temporarily, leaving behind content creation was
one of the hardest decisions I've had to make. The journey to
building a following, creating engaging content, and fostering
a community is incredibly fulfilling to me, but I realized that
my family's needs weren't being met. My faith in Christ teaches
me to prioritize my family's well-being above all else. And it
be okay, this is a good part to the video. Okay,
this is like a this is actually like he is talking about why
he's had to give up things. I I think as long as he's putting
his family first, this is like it won't work. It can't work.
There's 0% chance it'll work, but at least he's not like sacrificing
something that, you know, he can't get >> Hain clear that
my current path wasn't helpful in that. This decision ultimately
was driven by the need for financial responsibility and stability
in a more secure manner than just hoping for the next piece of
content to pop off. While this meant lowering the amount of time
that I invest into my content creation passion, overall it was
a choice root in love for my family. Balancing my faith with
family responsibilities required me to step outside of my comfort
zone and back into the workforce. But I trust that this temporary
sacrifice was small and in part of a greater plan that will allow
me to fulfill both my spiritual and familial commitments. With
that new full-time job, personal time became a rare commodity.
Each day I navigate a tight schedule where every minute counts
and aimlessly watching TV for hours or even scrolling through
Tik Tok was completely a scarce concept for me. I've had to drastically
reduce the time spent on those kinds of things and utilize that
reduj
he will figure out how to cure the lack of literal neurological
path in his brain that would have been developed over his childhood
and be the first geriatric pro gamer. Yeah, that is really the
rough thing, right? Like I think most people by the time they're
like 13, 14 have started doing like whatever game they go pro
at, it's like 12, 13, 14 is like when you start playing, right?
Like if you're not if you're missing like even that if you're
like starting games at like 18, 19, you actually might have a
bit of a rough time. It's not impossible
at all, but like you could have
you could have a rough time. Peak at 25, you are wrong. You start
if you start playing early enough, you will not peak at 25. You
will peak way earlier than that. Yeah. >> did time >> most
of most of like my friends who played games and didn't play games
as young as I did and didn't play like competitive games. Yeah.
Like playing competitive games I Dude, I played Overwatch with
some friends at like a a local van once and it was like it was
crazy like how bad like platinum players are. It was insane.
It was like you just do whatever you want. I could just like
go to and like dominate people. It's stupid. Right. Kelly Kelly's
on the right track. Okay. I say this like it's super cool but
objectively okay
I was getting nothing okay people it was not cool it wasn't like
super cool okay >> back into content creation so that I
can start playing games later on this has been a challenging
adjustment for sure as I previously held my time playing clone
hero and watching anime like Attack on Titan in high esteem.
However, this personal time sacrifice is a strategic choice aimed
at a future where I can potentially return to content creation
full-time. Although my current situation limits that personal
enjoyment and leisure, I'm hopeful that these sacrifices will
eventually lead to a future where I can fully immerse myself
in content creation again, backing my passions with financial
stability. Preparing for the OWCS has required a high level of
dedication, particularly when it comes to practice. To ensure
I'm at the top of my game, I've sacrificed regular restful sleep
to dedicate more hours to >> Well, that's good. You know,
I didn't realize he was just going to give up regular restful
sleep in order to make his dreams come true. That seems like
a totally sustainable and and likely to succeed initiative.
Guys, I've given up what did he say? How did he put it exactly?
That's insane. >> A high level of dedication, particularly
when it comes to practice. To ensure I'm at the top of my game,
I've sacrificed regular restful sleep to dedicate more hours
to honing my skills. Each night, I push beyond the typical bedtime
routine and sacrifice part of that 8 hours of sleep that is considered
essential commonly for your >> I don't think mo do most
people think 8 hours is essential for sleep. I feel like six
is my number. If I get six or more, I'm good.
>> Feel like you get over eight and it's like suddenly
feel like laggy. health and daily functioning. This commitment
to improving my game play often leaves me running on less than
ideal rest, which is challenging but currently necessary to keep
pace with the competition. I remind myself frequently that these
sleepless nights are a shortterm sacrifice to aid a long-term
goal. After all of this, I am finally at a place where my daily
routine is starting to turn out results. My days
>> diamond ridiculously planned where my daily routine
is starting to turn out. >> Wait, he hit diamond 9 months
ago. Oh, maybe he is okay. Maybe he'll make it.
>> My days are meticulously planned and they typically
start about 4:15 a.m. and end at 11:30 p.m. >> Yeah, that
is not remotely sustainable in any way. I can't wait for the
Where's the video saying how insane that was. >> My morning
begins with a quick boost of freshen up energy to kickstart my
day. You can use my code hope for 20% off your order and to help
aid me in this journey. By 4:45 a.m., I transition into a time
of prayer and Bible study, focusing on deepening my >> brother,
I don't have any pro I don't have any problem with Christians,
but like, bro, you're not this is not dedication to Overwatch,
okay? >> A relationship with Christ. From 5:15 to 6:15,
I dedicate an hour to solo Q Overwatch 2, striving to improve
my skills as a player. Next, I head to my work's employee onlyly
gym, being sure to crank up some gym hype music on the way there
before working out from 6:45 to 7:30 a.m. After cleaning up,
I commute to work, often arriving around 8:30 in the morning.
I work as a teller until 12:30 in the afternoon, then spend roughly
30 minutes editing each week's YouTube video to free up family
time later in my day. My workday then continues after that lunch
break until 5:00 p.m. followed by a commute home. Evenings are
precious, so I spend time with my family over dinner from 5:30
to 6:30. Then it's time to prepare for scrims with my team. Hope
>> God, this guy's so wholesome. I like actually wish this
was remotely possible for him to succeed.
I wish it was like even a tiny bit possible.
He's like so wholesome, but I This guy's a successful YouTuber.
He's got 10,000 8.7K subs. 8.8K maybe. He's like wholesome. I
want his like family to work and but it just doesn't I wish it
was possible. >> Opium from 700 p.m. to 9:00 p.m. Afterward,
I write and record a vertical video until 10:00 p.m. Then edit
more of these YouTube videos until 10:30. I wrap up each day
cuddling and watching a show with my wife from 10:30 to 11:30
p.m. I will say, as much as a consistent schedule is going to
aid me in this journey, another thing that is equally as important
is trying new things as a player. In this video right here, I
try to play Reinhardt in the way that Awkward teaches in his
unranked 2GM series.
You should check that out next.
>> Okay. All right.
So, where are we jumping to? I think next we're going to go to
this Overwatch Pro guy. He's going to watch this guy play. Okay.
>> Watch this guy play a little bit. VOD >> I want
the lore on this guy. >> Let's check it out. >> And
everything. Okay. Get your notepads out. 28 years old. Two kids
and a wife. can only play the game like 1 hour a day. He's going
pro. >> Two hours a day, but it's not really in the schedule.
Very well, I guess. >> Quit his job. Ran out of his emergency
fund. Bald.
>> This bald. Uhoh. >> Don't even think he got the
emergency fund yet. Isn't that the point? That's why he cannot
even >> Oh, no. This is 3 weeks ago. This is 3 weeks ago.
This 3 weeks ago. He might have started playing.
>> this is 3 weeks ago for his life. >> He actually
managed to pay off the debt and get an emergency fund. I don't
know. I I actually don't know, Kelly, but I'm guessing we'll
get an update, so let's keep checking. >> Okay, here we
go. >> I'm just watching his gameplay. He's playing some
Doomfist. I see. Did he biff that? I don't even know. Didn't
play Doomfist, though. >> He got charge punch. Okay. All
right. So, he f He farmed Charge Punch. >> We just need
to back out here, buddy. Yeah, you're just >> He's not
going pro.
>> Unfortunate. I can't evaluate Doomfist game. So right
now >> he is basically doing nothing. What I would like
from him, what I would like from him here is to to try to >> I
thought this was not going to suck. I feel like this sucks. >> He's
letting >> Can I watch him play Reinhardt or >> Set
the GoPro. >> That is unex.
It's you. So first that sucks. I've got nothing. I thought I
was going to watch this. Do we have any of the scrims? Let me
see if we can find some of the scrims. Hold on. Let me see if
we can find a scrim. Let me look. Let me look. Let me look.
Videos.
Scrim. Can we go to Scrim? Oh, let's go. Opium versus Blitz Gaming.
>> Because we're going to mirror their JQ >> It's
from a year ago >> right off the bat. >> Yep. A forward
corner.
>> I was just holding back. >> What the [__]
is this?
>> Reinhardt rush and junk instead of whatever you >> I
can evaluate Reinhardt gameplay. Okay. Let's see. What do we
We want to go on the sim here first. 100%.
>> Yo, let's go. Let's go.
>> All right.
>> Let's go.
>> right now.
>> Mr. Flare. I don't know, dude. Scroll up. Yeah, sure.
>> Can you call our targets? Can we call our targets? >> Sorry.
I'm just watching his gameplay.
I'm on the sim. I'm on the sim. I'm on the sim.
>> this is nuts.
>> Okay. Uh, what do we have? >> Ah, it's
>> Yeah. Um,
>> you switch. What is this character? I don't know what
this character is with the staff. You switch off of Reinhardt,
bro. I don't know. >> This just kind of feels weird. I
don't know. This content is weird. >> Uh, that's okay,
Kelly. You don't have to you don't have to like it. It's okay
if you don't like it. Ramatha, I don't know what Ramatha is.
What the? Time to switch this over to a coding stream. Nah, I
am going to go back to this guy's other stuff because I I grabbed
a couple videos here and I want to go through them. The the scrim
stuff I need this guy to explain. Suffice to say, this guy as
of three weeks ago kind of still sucks. Okay, I think we all
knew that was going to be the case. This is the next one of the
next videos in the series. Okay,
>> three months ago.
>> All right, have a good night, Kelly. Talk to you later.
Bye >> bye. Okay. Debunking more popular lies about my
Overwatch journey. All right.
>> That are ready to make judgments on people who they
barely know. News flash. Even after watching this video, you
still won't know me perfectly. But answering these questions
will help those who really want to know. So, I'm guessing he
gets a lot of criticism for trying to go pro at Overwatch at
28 with like nothing else going on. Okay. Like I think I think
you know you got kids, you got a wife. I
think this is rough. Not >> So, the very first question
I'm going to address today is whether or not I have a full-time
job and or how do I pay the bills? And this actually normally
comes in the form of hatred where people tell me that I am terrible
at this game and that I need to go get a full-time job.
There are a lot of haters who say I suck, okay, and need to get
work. But you you don't understand. We're gaming for hope. This
isn't This isn't pro gamer hour, okay? It's gaming for hope.
I need hope. Stop taking my hope >> job. It's kind of one
of those similar attitude of don't quit your day jobs kinds of
things. And I I mean, case in point, I get it. But to answer
your question, when I first started my Overwatch Champion series
journey, it was actually still when the Overwatch League was
around and I wanted very badly to be a full-time creator. So,
at the time, I had made a lot of
I want to see his flick. Let's see the flicks, bro. Show me your
flicks.
You got McCree. You got you got McCree out here or whatever the
he's called now. He's called something else. Why' they rename
him? Dude, the guy, right? The guy who's actually McCree or something.
And so they're like, we have to rename McCree now. Which is so
stupid. Like Blizzard, the one time we want it covered up. Okay.
The one time we want to cover it up so I can keep calling him
McCree.
No. Stfu. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. McCree. Overwatch.
Cassidy. They call him Why is Cassidy called McCree? He was named
McCree in Overwatch one. He was named after a Blizzard employee
who later got in trouble for sexual harassment in the workplace.
So they renamed the character as the name carried some bad background
with it. I told you. I told you. Oh, I said the character the
guy who he was named after. Whatever. Sorry. The guy who was
named after not actually obviously it's a like meme. It's a condensing.
No shot. Matt Mercer. Sorry. I meant the guy who uh I I might
have said the guy who played him. I meant the guy who made the
character. the Blizzard employee. It was a Blizzard employee
who wrecked. Okay.
Yes, they've renamed him Cassidy. Now he's not even McCree anymore.
But I need to see this guy's flick shots. Show me some flicks.
Flick. Flick to a couple heads or take care of your family. Flick
to a couple of heads or start focusing on becoming the assistant
manager at your bank job or whatever the Okay, I need some flick
shots now or quit this. Quit this absurd pantomime. You're not
never going to be a pro gamer. All right, give it up >> and
decided to basically eliminate as many expenses as I could. And
by doing that, it allowed me to be a full-time creator way earlier
than probably most people get to. I was also living with my in-laws
at the time, so things were just in a really good spot to do.
Things went fairly poorly financially because I made some very
poor financial decisions and I ended up needing to go get a 9
to5. >> Please tell me you invested in like some Please
tell me you invested in some. Could you imagine if he threw a
bunch of money in some coin and then he >> worked for a
local bank for a little bit and found myself more irritable,
deeply unfulfilled, and despite the fact that I had a lot more
money than I did before, I was just miserable and I needed to
make a change. So, I went back to being a full-time creator very
recently, and we're still living with my in-laws, but we're working
on getting out of debt so that we can actually move out very
comfortably. I think that we're at that point now. The creator
community side of things has been phenomenal. I've got a truly
wonderful community that has come in clutch in so many scenarios
in my life. I realized that if I just give them something that
is worth watching and worth being a part of, I believe >> he
started streaming, right? He definitely had to have started streaming.
I could see people tuning in for live streams, some longer live
streams. Two hours, two hours. Yeah, he's streaming a quite a
bit. Two times a week. Yeah. Hey,
I'll say, you know, you can give this guy a lot of Oh, never
mind. Uh, the videos fell off pretty hard. This is the big one
that this all came out about. But um before that he Oh, never
mind. He doesn't put out that many videos. I thought he put out
a lot of videos every week. Is his aim fully wristed? I can't
tell if he's stray faming. Um
see here >> that the dollars will naturally follow. Question
number two, how much time do I actually spend with my family?
And this one's really again one of those rephrased, you know,
hatefilled comments where someone said, "Quit doing this. Spend
more time with your family. Just hang up the mouse." sunk. It's
really funny they say hang up the mouse cuz my mouse is wireless.
So, jokes's on you.
>> Jokes on them. >> Okay, that was a stupid dad
joke. I don't regret it, but I definitely made it and here we
are. But to answer the question very directly, on my regular
calendar, the things that I do at a minimum is 30 hours a week.
And that includes time with my kids, just in and of themselves,
and time with my bride every single day. So for those of you
that don't think that I spend time with my family, I actually
spend more time on with my family that is dedicated on average
than the vast majority of dads, especially in the US. The third
question >> I can see that being true. >> Again,
you'll see >> I think probably people are saying this to
you though more on the line along the lines of like, hey, you
need to be taking care of your family. You can't just live with
your in-laws. That seems uh you know, you know, >> a theme
here. It's me basically responding to my haters. Do I actually
think I'll ever compete in the OwCS? It's a great question and
you have to have a really clear mindset to answer it without
being personally hurt by people who may actually be asking a
genuine question. And the answer is yes. If I didn't think I
could actually compete in the OWCS at the level I intend to compete
at, I would not be baiting all of you into following an account
whose basis is the idea of an underdog story that I'd be able
to compete in the OWCS as a 20's father with three children.
I would not bait you guys into doing that. And anybody who watches
my streams, you guys, I would hope know by now that I have a
bit more integrity than that. If I wasn't being serious about
this, I would not continue to do this. Another question that
comes in fairly frequently, and this one's less hateful, but
definitely a really valid question, is why don't I change my
hero pool depending on the meta that is currently going, and
that is because I firmly believe in the idea that the more time
you spend playing certain heroes, the better you get at those
heroes, and the less meta actually affects your hero. as an example.
>> Okay, the answer to this should not be that. The trick
to getting better at these games as quickly as possible is to
OTP. Okay, you should OTP if you're not stupid because there
are so many aspects to this game that you absorb that you absorb
passively.
You need to be playing at the highest level possible because
you will absorb like certain things passively as you get to these
higher levels, right? So the biggest priority you should have
is to be able to queue solo by yourself at the highest level
possible at any given time, right? You want to get better, but
like you also want to so
this kind of conflicts with like not caring about wins and losses.
You should be otping because you want to get into a higher MMR
bracket. One trick pony, one trick pony. Uh you want to be playing
one character only. You want to get really, really, really good
at one character only, right? So you can rise up the MMR ladders,
the yellow ladder as fast as you can. And you want to actually,
bro, will you with how behind you are now compared to other players,
can you really afford to ignore meta? Oh, see that's the thing
is like you maybe switch on on meta shifts or something, but
I'm saying you you like get really good at one character because
you're always going to pick up more stuff out of playing at a
higher level than uh anywhere else. Yeah, it's like it's just
really important. Um, and this this guy's up by having like a
hero pool. You should have a hero puddle, >> Many of you
that watch my content know that I am a Zarya main. I do play
Div.A and Sigma as well, but Zarya is by far the hero that I
have the most hours in as far as tank is concerned. Zarya has
been kind of a hated tank for a while because she's either unbelievably
busted or she's like terrible and there seems to be no in between
in a lot of people's minds. What's important to understand is
once I get her fundamentals down as a hero, I will be able to
play her in metas where she's not necessarily favored. Now, once
you get to the OWCS, does that change? Of course it does. I'm
not ignorant. There is a balancing act where you realize that
yes, the OWCS that matters, but I'm not there yet. I got a little
ways to go. And once I have a hero like Zarya, Div.A, or Sigma
down to a science. That means I probably understand how to play
tank well enough that picking up another hero because of the
meta when I'm on a team for the OWCS will not be nearly as difficult
as me trying to just change my hero pull all the time and never
really allowing myself to understand what it is to be a tank
player fully. All right, question number five. How >> That's
actually like not the worst answer I've seen. Okay, >> how
many hours do I have in competitive? Well, I couldn't remember
them all off top of my head, so for the sake of this video, I
actually wrote them all down. As of me recording this video,
I have 716 hours in competitive.
>> Dude, I feel like almost certainly I could go to my
Overwatch competitive from the first two seasons years and years
and years ago, and have significantly more hours than this. Hold
on, I'll I'll just pull Okay,
lots of this was leaving the game open. Okay. Lost this was leaving
the game open, but like I just I just popped open Steam real
quick. Okay. Unrelated game. I think I've probably played more
hours in Overwatch than he has. But unrelated game. Okay. Unrelated
game. Last played December 18th, 2021.
8,911
hours. Okay, we don't [__] around.
We do not [__] around. Okay, we do not. You want
to be good at something, you grind. You grind.
I think I used to leave Dota open a lot. I think there was a
while like early on in Dota where if you were watching stuff
you could get drops. So there's a lot of like auto watching tournaments
and stuff so that you could get drops and I do open a lot. So
anyway, I feel like you were an EG stand. Not until RTZ joined
>> overall and as you can tell most of them are not in
DPS. 374 of those hours. Uh, the very sickening thing about this
is I probably have like six smurf accounts that would be different
Steam accounts and have different number of hours. And I've definitely
hit like, man, I hit pretty high MMRs. Like I was playing against
pro players on like multiple of the accounts. So >> are
on support. 259 of those hours are >> Although I say that
that sounds really good. Uh, in one of the tinker patches, I
just spammed tinker mid and I got good enough at like cheesesing
with tinker mid that I got like really high, like way higher
than my actual MMR was. So, it's not that's probably like not
fair. Tank and a total of 81 hours of those are on DPS. Again,
as you probably knew, while this one's an easier question to
answer, I do also think it's important to answer a subset of
question that comes from that a lot is if I have been playing
tank for 259 hours and I've peaked diamond 4 and realistically
held platinum, how do I ever expect to get to the OWCS with time?
Because >> no, actually that is not the right question.
I think 250 hours in Diamond 4 is like not even that bad. It's
not even like horrible. The issue is that you get 250 hours in
and you want to be pro. That's the issue here. I when I stream,
I am streaming
maybe this is why I was able to stream so much from the very
beginning. I This is like the lowest volume time for me streaming
in like the entire time I've streamed. And I think I'm at like
150 hours in a month. This is like the most time I've ever taken
off. Let me see. In the past month, 146 hours in the past month,
right? I usually clock in at like 190 to 200 hours a month. That's
been typical, right, of just streaming. So like this guy in a
month, I would expect you to be able to like and that's what
other people are putting into Overwatch when they want to be
pros, right? That's what they're putting into Overwatch. You
should be hitting like 200 hours a month in Overwatch. 250 hours
in the what this would be
first video was October of 2024. So this is like six months later.
Five months later, he's doing this video. In 5 months, you've
gotten 250 hours and you would have had way more before that,
right? It's weak. It's weak. >> The cold hard reality is
unless you have a natural talent, anything that you want to get
better at takes more time. You have to get better. >> No,
no, no, no. Natural talent's garbage. Don't Don't think about
natural natural talent doesn't matter in these games. Everybody
they ever claim is naturally talented. No life these games. Okay.
There's a there's this guy in Dota 2 named Anna. Anatham fan.
He's like uh he was like supposed to be legendary cuz he came
out of nowhere and was like one of the best players in the professional
scene after not really being known in the professional scene.
You know what he did before that? He no life the game 16 hours
a day for like a year and a half in China. He moved to China
just to no life pub the game for like 16 hours a day, right?
That's and people are like, "Oh, he's so naturally talented."
No, he's not. He went to China and had zero life and himself.
Okay. Figuratively
10 hours a week. Yeah. That is never happening. There's no natural
talent for these games. You play a lot until it becomes like
second nature, until you literally see it in your life. Okay?
>> And the only way you get better is by investing the
time. I keep saying that and there's a reason I keep repeating
the phrase. In order to master anything, you have to get 10,000
hours. So, do I think I'm going to have this game mastered before
I get in the OCS? Of course not. But do I think that I'm going
to have it in a level that will allow me to get into the top
50 teams of the competition? Absolutely. Number six, why aren't
you on a scrim team currently if your goal is to compete in a
team-based game? Totally valid question. Let me explain a little
bit. So, currently speaking, I have a certain amount of hours
that I can invest into this being my full-time job. And because
I'm just starting out as a creator, and that's been primarily
what pays my bills in the last little while. I have to make sure
that content goes out that is worth watching, and that requires
time invested, that exceeds the amount of time that it would
take for me to be available for a scrim team. Right now, I'm
also sitting in platinum, which tells me that I don't have anywhere
near the understanding of tank.
he's sitting in platinum again. So, he fell out of diamond. He's
still not like guaranteed like getting through platinum. He like
fell out of plat fell out of diamond back into platinum as of
March of this year, as of four months
That's brutal. And that should be that should be proof that you
need to get the >> that I need in order to really contribute
to a team. >> Saying there is no natural talent is insane.
Uh it's way less insane for video games versus like obviously
you could be born a woman or something and then you're just but
like for everybody else for the rest of humanity. Okay, we do
have there's no differentiation on genetics that will [__]
you over.
I'm sorry. I I wholeheartedly believe that. That is the one ultra
misogynist opinion I have. I am sorry. There's something about
being born a woman. You will never be professional in video games
to the extent that guys are. You will never be the best player.
It just will not happen. I don't know if it's genetic in terms
of like determination, if it's genetic in terms of like hand
eye coordination. I actually don't know what it is. It is just
the way it is. And I'm sorry. What about Starcraft? You have
to be Korean. You're totally discounting
who by the way was another guy that they're like, "This guy is
so pro. This guy says he only practices one hour a week. That
guy no life Warcraft 3 every single day of his entire life."
Okay, that guy was a professional player in another uh RTS game.
Anyway, isn't it sample size also? No, it's not. But um sample
size helps a lot. I would say also that that only applies to
what do you call it? Like reaction games. So, probably like RTS,
probably like there could be strategy games, right? Let's say
or card games, Magic the Gathering, Hearthstone. I think women
would obviously be able to compete in that. There has to be like
a a like skill, timing, time pressure element to it that that
pushes people. I know I know chess doesn't work, but
yeah, there's something about chess, too. I don't know. I don't
know. >> Well, because when you join a team anyway, that's
like the one gigam misogynist opinion I have. It sucks. But it
I I'll like defend that and I will just tell people like point
out where I'm wrong. Point out where this is incorrect because
as far as I can tell this is just the way it is, bro.
All right. It It just is the way it is. >> What you're
actually trying to learn is not how to play your role as much
as how to play your role with a team. Those are the big distinctions
there. So until I >> I can't stress enough as well that
how well you play a role with a team matters about 2%.
how well you play the game, how well you play the game in like
a solo setting is like 98%.
That's why in like Dota and in Overwatch, you get like pub stars
who only pub, they only play pubs, they've never played competitive
before, and they can get so good playing pubs, they can reach
the top of the ladder that that they will get picked up for a
pro team and they will all they'll already be good on that team,
right? It's like there is such a minute tiny piece that is your
team communication and how you work with the team.
I I think people just don't understand it. So many matches where
one where one gets many kills but the team still loses. It's
not it's not like that. It's you you got to aim the weapon, okay?
You got to aim the gun. You got to make the decisions. It's not
about how well you communicate them. Sometimes you you will have
a lot of situations where you're going to outplay people individually
and you need to be winning those to be a pro. You don't need
to be winning them to be like uh all to be like a good player.
And communication can help especially in ranked, but it will
never be the thing that makes you a pro >> Have my roll
down. I don't see a reason to use a slot on a team as a tank
player until I'm ready for it. And I think that'll be around
the Mast's GM mark. And that time is coming. It just takes a
little bit of time. All right. This one's a fun question that
I actually had in my chat recently and we talked about it in
a live stream, but I decided it was a good thing to maybe put
into a video because of some other things I'm going to be doing
soon. What other kinds of things would I like to create content
in? And I actually have a couple of >> Oh yeah, sorry.
The non-misogynist take there is I'm positive that in every video
game that exists on the planet some woman could probably beat
me at it at this point, right? Like I could it's not saying that
like all men it's not doing the like upper body strength argument.
Like obviously women can get good at the games and women can
be like you know high latter ranked players. I just don't think
they'll ever be like the the top tier pros. Yeah. >> To
start a few other channels. But the next one that I will be starting
that isn't strictly Overwatch or even gaming related is a tech
channel where I focus on trying to encourage people to be minimal
with their purchases because you can get a lot of value for spending
way less money than the vast majority of people actually spend
on their hobbies. And tech is definitely one of the areas we
can sink the most money into.
The only woman good at SC2 is Scarlet. Well, it's a good thing
I opened up by saying
there's no such thing as natural talent unless you were born
a woman and then you don't have whatever natural talent is there.
So, I already I already cleverly angled around that argument.
All right. Very easily. So, I will actually be creating a channel
for that. I also intend to create a second Gaming for Hope channel,
something like Gaming for Hope 2, more Gaming for Hope, and it'll
be games that I just want to play, things that are more variety,
less Overwatch, less FPS even, and more just what I felt like
playing in that particular week. And I can just make a >> No,
that's unacceptable.
That's unacceptable. You're like taking time away from your kids
and your family and working to do this. You absolutely Please
don't. Please don't say, "Oh, well, I want to play some other
games. I want to play some other games, too." Shut the up. Pick
up to pick up the mouse, play Overwatch, or shut the up and be
a regular adult.
>> Fun video out of it for you guys because I think that
there will be an audience that will just enjoy me making content
at a certain point. And if I have other content that goes beyond
Overwatch, it also allows me to relate to more people than I
do currently. So I looked that as a very very very big win in
my book. I did mention there were four total channels. I'm sure
you realize Gaming for Hope itself is a channel in that list.
I know, big surprise. tech channel, the Gaming for Hope 2 channel,
and then finally a channel with my wife where we game together
and discuss things about relationships, marriage, the world as
it is, and just talk about real life topics because I think that
that's something that as a society we're shying away from, and
we really need to stop shying away from it. >> One second,
just talk about topics. >> We need to be comfortable talking
about the things that make us uncomfortable. All right. for a
fresh area. Maybe I'll >> like inherent human ability.
What's What's the There's like There's some really coded phrase
for like race realism that people use. There's something like
inherent human potential or something like that. There's like
a coded phrase here that I'm trying to think of. I wonder if
he's going to is he about to go on his Dr. Mike arc? Dude, Dr.
Mike the Dr. Mike thing where he tries to uh where he tries to
address his race realism take is so like dark and funny to me.
There are two pieces of information. There are two pieces of
information. One is that intelligence is highly heritable. Okay,
it's highly heritable. And two,
that there are genetic like clusters around race. If I put those
two pieces of information together or say anything more than
that, your buddy's off the internet. Okay. It's like he just
looks so deranged while he says it. It's like holy [__]
Let's go, Dr. Mike. >> Y'all actually stay. >> No
shot. He said that. You don't believe me? Hold on, Mike. Israel
intelligence.
Please give me the video. >> For example, I'll just cut
right into this. The GPT tells you because you asked it that
your race or ethnic group is not the most intelligent of all
of them and maybe somewhere down the totem pole much further
than you had anticipated. You may also discover at the same time
that there is a totem pole of racial intelligence and you're
going to go, "Holy, what?" You keep asking it. It's like this
is reality. You're like, "Oh my, does your DoD do I just stop
trying? What is this? Holy crap, that's a really big deal. It
could really bum you out." Now, inevitably, when you guys get
in the comments and ask me questions about race and intelligence,
here is my view in perpetuity until >> in perpetuity until
politics politics changes in the United States >> exchanges
in at least the United States. This is my view. Uh, >> dude,
I watched this clip so many times. It's so funny. as applied
forward for the rest of this channel's lifetime until and unless
politics really changes. Here it is. Ready? I 100% acknowledge
because I'm literate that race is truly a biological construct.
It is deep. It pervades almost everything and and it has real
world differences in ability that are complicated. They are overlapping
in spectra, but they are nonetheless for sure real and they affect
every single thing about your life on the margins. So the funny
thing about this is this is probably actually the accurate take,
right? Like he is saying it's not like consequent it's not so
consequential that you can't like live a happy fulfilled life
regardless of anything. It's like it's like on the margins it
affects little things and there will be like differences and
you should probably be aware of that if you care. Right.
This is this is his mask on take. Yeah. If you ask me any more
questions about that, I won't say anything because I'm not getting
cancelled over that [__] Because in our current political
climate, if I fill in the blanks of what I mean, your boy's out
that I'm not ready to, you know what I'm saying? Shut down the
YouTube yet. But so what I'm saying is, yes, race is real. Yes,
race differences exist. Yes, even in every single quality that
you think is too politically incorrect to talk about, which is
why I'm not going to talk about it. I got plenty of other to
say. >> Dude, this is like such a perfectly crafted clip,
too, because you know exactly what he thinks, right? You know,
I Is anybody confused about what he thinks? Nobody's confused.
It's obvious to everyone. He just got to say what he wanted to
say, and he has this on his YouTube channel. 64,000 views, not
>> Tons of other great stuff. But I, as a scientifically
literate, awake person, I have to say yes, I'm aware of these
things. Right, that's that. >> Sorry. Uh, oh yeah. So,
Game of Hope made me think of that. What did he say? It was like,
we need to be able to have uncomfortable conversations. >> Society,
we're shying away from and just talk about real life topics because
I think that that's something that as a society we're shying
away from and we really need to stop shying away from it. We
need to be comfortable talking about the things that make us
uncomfortable. All right. And for a fresh area, maybe I'll actually
stay here. This >> That's what I thought. That's what I
thought he meant >> this time. And with a fresh shot, the
question is, why not switch to rifles? Well, I did. And what
I found was that the game was severely lacking in the actual
competitive nature of the game. I don't think that the developers
want to do anything different with it. I think they want it to
be the casual game. And I like the game and I definitely want
to encourage you to enjoy what you enjoy. >> Bro, why wouldn't
he switch to rivals? Why wouldn't he just switch to rivals? That
would be like way better, wouldn't it? Isn't rivals like 100
times the >> And I enjoy rivals, but I do not take it as
seriously as I do Overwatch. I don't think anybody does because
the developers themselves don't even take it that seriously.
So, try to realize that and move forward with your life. The
ninth question, what makes me focus on being a wholesome content
creator and person? And this one's kind of a big one to unpack,
but I'm going to try and consolidate it into a couple of minutes.
The core of it all is my faith in Christ. And I understand that
not a lot. >> Okay, there's nothing else. The next one
is uh why am I so wholesome? Then this this was this question.
And then why don't I release more opinion based content like
tier lists? Okay,
more popular lies about my Overwatch journey was this one. I
think we're ready to go on to the big one. The big final video.
Okay, maybe not final, but uh
the biggest one.
Let's address these
The truth about the new accusations. I don't know what the new
accusations are. This guy, what did this guy do? Oh god. Oh no.
These claims, including being labeled as a Nazi, a KKK member,
or
are completely false.
Bro, it's that podcast where he wanted to speak openly about
uncomfortable topics. Uhoh.
Uhoh.
Uhoh. Shouldn't have done it. Shouldn't have done it.
He did. He did Dr. Mike it. He did Dr. Mike that the entirety
of the community of Overwatch seems to be at least aware of at
this point. I have notes in front of me. So if you see me looking
down, it is because I'm trying to be organized without literally
reading. >> Am I okay? I don't want to I don't want to
shame anybody. This guy kind of not look a little bit just a
little bit. There's like echoes cuz he's not this fat, but there's
like echoes a little bit of sick here, isn't there? Sick unchained.
Like slight echoes of sick unchained. Am I the only one who sees
it? I >> being a script. I mean I literally I'm There is
no script here. It may look like a script, but >> Sick's
a better looking guy than this guy. Sick is an absolutely better
looking guy than this guy. He's not fat like this guy. Okay,
I'm not saying that. I'm just saying I could sit. >> There
is no script. It is just my bullet points trying to help me keep
my thoughts organized. The allegations that I'm aware of at this
point are that I neglect my children. I'm anti-LGBTQIA+.
I'm a Nazi. Apparently, I'm still with this out of context screenshot
once again circulating Twitter. I wanted to share the context
for those of you who actually care or actually care to know.
The rest of y'all can remain in your delusion. Go to 518 on this
video and you'll see the context on this. Hold on. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. There's a hidden link on this page. Hold
on. Hold on. There's a hidden link on this page. I'm finding
Let me click through to this video. Let me click through this
video. One second. There's a hidden link. Hidden link. Hidden
link.
Oh, you really hold on, dude. Streamable me so hard. Not streamable.
This stupid like me so hard. Um, the move file is coming out
of Discord. I don't know how to fix this. Anyway, hidden link.
Hold on. This is his favorite video. This he linked this along
with that that salute. >> We got it.
>> Wait, why did why was this linked?
>> That's crazy.
I don't know why he linked that video there. Okay. The truth
about the new accusations. >> Considered to be a member
of the KKK. I am unemployed. I groomed my wife, which is insane
to say out loud. Applies reaction, which obviously was a lot
of what sparked this whole chaotic mess. And not that that's
his fault, just to be clear. And then I'm going to share an adjustment
to my goals in general at the end of the video. There will be
chapters. So, if there's a specific question that you want to
go look at the answer to, you don't care about anything else,
totally fine. Uh, skip to that one. It's okay. I'm going to throw
this disclaimer out there though before I say anything about
any of the >> This is rough. This is going to be like,
dude, this guy almost certainly just takes like troll comments
super seriously, right? Somebody's like, here's these Christians.
They're like, you hate gays, don't you? He's like, you think
I hate gays? I have to deal with these allegations now. It's
like, no, that's not that's not what's happening. >> The
allegations. My request to you is very clear. Treat people.
Of >> course they are intentionally doing. Do not be disrespectful
to me or anybody else in my comment section. It takes me or one
of my moderators 2 seconds to hide your account. Please don't
make us do that. You are welcome to leave criticism in the comments.
You are even welcome to be critical of me. What will be blocked
is people who are clearly rage baiting and people who are clearly
just there to be toxic and not helpful. So, first let's talk
about this whole I neglect my children thing based on a very
very very deeply outofc context clip. as is. You'll find a theme
as we continue. Basically, what was going on there is my kid
was crying. It's my youngest son, Cassie, >> endorsed his
crying child to prioritize losing his 3.1K ELO scrim >> and
was crying in the background. My stream is actually in our bedroom,
and he's 6 months old, so he has a bassinet that's next to our
bed. So, he was being put down for bed about that time, and my
wife was with him, so he was not being neglected. My wife is
a stay-at-home mom. So, her entire life is built around making
our home wonderful and raising our children in a very direct,
consistent way. And oh, that is good math. Yes, that is another
kid, isn't
That's another kid. There's a third. No, no, no.
Who pays the bills? Uh, his steparents. Her parents
apparently pay the bills.
They live with them. He said he lives with his in-laws. while
I continue to earn a living and provide for the family. That's
not everybody's way of doing things, by the way. I don't care.
That's fine. If something else works better for you and your
family, that's great. But for us, her being a stay-at-home mom
and homemaker has been a huge blessing, not only for my children,
but for me when I come home from work, it is a very big deal.
Kids do cry, in case you didn't know that.
I don't think have ever >> Hold on. Is he back to working
full-time again? cuz as of three months before this, yeah, I
think three months before this, I think he was not working full-time.
He's back to content creation >> Had children, which is
fine. But you do need to be a little more sensitive to the fact
that kids cry. That's just their way of communicating. They cry
when they need changed. They cry when they're hungry. They cry
when they're cold. They cry when they're hot. They cry. You get
the idea. They cry a lot. And if you've watched any of my streams
for more than just that one clip's duration, you know that especially
during the nights that I'm not in a scrim, which is like literally
every one of them besides that one cuz I was just trial. The
first video we watched, he talked about going back to work. In
the second video we watched or third video we watched actually,
the one where he was doing an update and addressing some lies
about him. He said that he was really miserable working and so
he went back to full-time content creation just recently. That
one was from March 2025. That's less than four months ago, like
three and a half months ago. ing for a scrim team. I walk >> wait
sorry three and a half months ago. Yeah, three and a half months.
>> Way after that game when I'm done with a game and my
wife needs something. I have a BRB scene specifically so that
I can walk away from my stream and people know that I'm gone
for a minute because my wife does need my help sometimes. My
streams also lie about the middle of them is when my kids go
to bed. I usually walk away from here for a minute to go say
good night to them, tuck them in, and then I come back. The audacity
for people to think that I don't care about my children or that
I'm neglecting them is astronomical. Let's I mean
I can believe it though, right? Like you could understand how
people end up there and how trolls would get there too. Explicitly
you are a 28-year-old man with a family with a wife and kids
who has decided to take instead of your time to build towards
like a meaningful career, you're being building towards being
an Overwatch bro. If you were just building towards being a content
creator, that would be like an order of magnitude less sad. would
still be very sad, but it' be an order of magnitude less sad.
You're like doing the most unstable job on earth, hoping it'll
work and like living off your in-laws, right? That is that's
the issue here. That's why people think you might be abusing
your kids or neglectful of your kids is because you've made decisions
that indicate that your long-term priorities are not on your
kids, right? You could say, "Oh, well, I take really good care
of them." But it's like, "Dude, are you guys going to be homeless?
What happens if your steparents die? What happens if uh I don't
know like your house gets like knocked down and they don't have
insurance. I don't know like maybe maybe her parents are rich
or something and maybe he just never has to >> talk about
the LGBTQIA plus community because I do want to say before I
say anything else I >> Oh, sure. Sure. The short also
could have just been trolls. It could just be trolls. But I I
absolutely get why
possibly like you could say this guy's like not good with his
kids, right? I I understand how people could have that that like
that thought at a base level. What does he keep saying? Steparents.
Why wouldn't you say? Oh, in-laws. Yeah, sure. Yeah, it's exactly
K though. It's easy to control uh concern troll over. It's very
easy to concern troll over. Realistically, you don't really know.
And it sounds like to me, it sounds like he's been prioritizing
his kids from the beginning. At least to make sure that they're
not like super put off by this. >> I have nothing but kindness
and love in my heart for you. Yes, I have my own personal beliefs
as a Christian, but those beliefs are anchored by the idea that
you are to love your neighbor as yourself. And I know that while
the Bible calls many of the LGBTQIA plus community
identifications
sin, that does not mean that I am without fault. I make mistakes
constantly, and the Bible has no hierarchy to sin. >> There's
a good answer, but I don't know. Would it make sense if all they
did was say, "Oh, you hate gays because you're religious." I
feel like there's got to be some comments, right? There's got
to be some there there or else this just goes away. >> There
is no the LGBT is is the worst. Although some Christians would
have you believe that, there's just no factual basis for that.
my lying on occasion, little white lie, even just a little, you
know, you steal a paper clip from your office, that's still as
bad in God's mind according to the Bible as anything else that's
listed as sin in the Bible. It's all the same to him. At my core,
you will never ever ever.
>> That can't be true. Stealing a paperclip is the same
as a guy in the app. I don't know about that. I think sodomy
was like kind of penalized. Yes.
I don't I don't think so. I >> never ever ever be able
to find a place where I am disrespectful towards someone because
of >> Listen, I didn't go I didn't spend that much time
in Sunday school, so I really don't know. I feel like that's
not for us to judge. Sure, that's not for us to judge. True.
>> Of their gender identity,
orientation, or the like. I can promise you that. I obviously
made a video about Venture when they were released into the game.
And notice, even as I'm talking about Venture now, I still use
their preferred pronouns, even though I don't personally align
with it, which I said then and I stand by it now. My personal
beliefs should never impact the way that I respect and treat
other people. Period. I want you to know when I posted that video
about venture, >> I off Christians that I know personally
because I wouldn't outright say that I hate, and I mean this,
this is genuine, because I wouldn't say that I hate the
I promise you this is a real thing that happened. I was so n
that I off both sides of the argument. >> Wow. I'm shocked
that that could possibly be a thing. Dude, I'm h
nobody is going to care at all in this, right? It's like, could
you imagine somebody who's racist saying this if it wasn't um
LGBTQ people and
and and uh Christians, right? some racist dude is like, "Listen,
I said that black people are just as good as the rest of us,
and you have no idea how mad how mad that made the people at
my KKK meetings, okay?
You have no idea how mad it made them." But guys, can you understand
that I'm making a sacrifice at home, too? I don't think I don't
think that's really going to help. I'm sorry if that doesn't
tell you enough about this. I don't know what will. Just to reiterate,
you can live your life the exact way you want to live it. I will
not be against you in that. I will not vote against you in that.
You will not find me in the opposition despite my personal beliefs
because my personal beliefs are what I align my life to, not
yours. Also, I will say there was a relatively funny. I have
to I have to admit I had a good laugh. Funny clip of me jumping
over the rainbow crosswalk at Midtown. Uh, I thought that was
quite funny. It was completely out of context. The top portion
of my camera feed was I don't even know where they grabbed that.
That's kind of funny. probably my Doomfist video where I'm jumping
around a lot. But
the other thing is um I that gameplay is not my footage and the
line that was said is the only
>> only thing that was actually real and I want to give
the context to that. I basically said something along the lines
of I don't do the whole preferred pronouns thing. Someone asked
me right before that what my preferred pronouns were. And I said
to them something strongly along the lines of you can call me
by what I present to you because I believe that's how it should
be. I don't really go the preferred pronouns route for me for
me. And that's >> I'm glad he's addressing these really
really terrible comments. >> It's insane to me that we've
gotten to this point that people actually think that I just said
that as a general statement on the internet. That's a so wild.
I also >> would that really be I don't really care about
Well, maybe I do care. I don't know. I don't think it's like
a wild statement though to not care about preferred pronouns.
>> Left a comment replying to someone who unfortunately
turns out was just rage baiting me and was not being authentic
whatsoever in their question of what I was doing for Pride Month.
And I responded with, I don't celebrate Pride Month, which is
correct. I don't force you on Easter to celebrate Christ's resurrection,
nor do I force you to celebrate Christ's birth at Christmas.
>> Okay, this is really funny cuz I can see how it would
off like uh gigasoys on Tik Tok. Okay, to compare You're just
going to compare gays who exist to your fake sky god Jesus and
his birthday. You're just going to you're just going to compare
these? I can see how it people off. Okay, I can see how it make
people mad. It's very funny. That's not your beliefs. Period.
End of story. And I'm not going to force it on you. I'm just
asking that you do the same for me. For some reason, that concept
is so foreign to today's day and age because of how polarized
we are as a complete society. This isn't just a United States
thing. This is a worldwide issue. The Overwatch community is
super prog. I know. They canceled Sinatra. What did Sinatra even
do to you guys? Okay. What did that guy do? I can't remember
that exactly. I remember seeing the Sinatra thing. We should
like actually cover the Sinatra thing because at the time I remember
being like, "This guy's getting railroaded." Like, "This guy's
actually getting just totally over right now." That was my opinion
on the Sinatra thing, but I don't No, not Sinatra was an Overwatch
pro. We make the Hassan laugh points goal lower. No.
No. Technicals has a good video on Sinatra. Maybe we'll watch
it at some point. He basically had a video like his girlfriend
accused him of being like a narcissistic abuser, which I totally
believe, which is not against the law. You probably shouldn't
be canceled for being like just narcissistic, being like an in
relationship. But then she had a video of her going like, "No,
stop. Stop." And he was doing something and he doesn't stop,
right? I swear to God. Not even a good Hassan laugh. Shut up.
Yes, it is. And the but the audio the audio I think there's like
a situation.
It sounded Sorry, it did sound bad now that I remember. It did
sound It sounded like bad, but I was like, "Dude, I could I need
more." It was really tightly clipped, right? It was really tightly
clipped and I don't think you could hear the whole thing. And
I Oh, man. We should watch it cuz I remembered at the time, but
also all of the Overwatch community wanted to cancel that guy.
This guy, no, a different guy. I'm off topic on the Sinatra thing.
Anyway, sorry. I'll hit play on this. I'm gonna get a drink.
I'll be right back. because we have been continually polarized
and separated and forced apart when I guarantee you I guarantee
you that if we didn't have all of this media BS crammed down
our throat all day long that we were inundated with regardless
if it's traditional news media like Fox or MSNBC or if you get
your news from Twitter or if you get where X you got one >> game
it for hope don't say who controls the media game it for hope
no
don't talk about who controls the media game it for hope, please.
>> I'm saying Tik Tok, whatever. Unfortunately, we are
so inundated with media that we get continually forced further
and further and further apart. So that if you disagree,
the goal is that you will never stand united on what really matters.
Please don't take that as your opinions don't matter. They do
matter. That's okay. You should stand for them. That's appropriate.
That's especially if you live in the United States. soldiers
and men and women all over the world have died for those rights.
I'm not trying to take those from you. I wasn't even going to
put this out there at all this particular section, but because
I've had enough people reach out to me personally to clarify
my stance, I felt like it was appropriate to include it here.
All right, let's talk about the fact that evidently according
to the internet who is so wonderfully versed in history that
I see according to them. So, you're seeing the image on your
screen right now. Fair enough that you see that at first glance,
but there are two key important things. Number one is the one
thing that a simple Google search of what a Nazi salute look.
>> He's uh there's one very sad thing, guys, okay, that
you don't understand here. He is the one thing that's actually
worse than a Nazi, okay? He's an Elon Musk fan. He's an actual
Elon Musk fan. >> Like would have answered for you. I used
the wrong hand. If it was an actual Nazi soldier, what it would
have been my right hand in your left hand, you would have been
shot and killed in the Nazi Germany. So, uh, little history le.
>> That's not a defense. That is not
that is not a defense. >> But the more important thing
is that was a screenshot from one of my videos that was taken
completely out of context where I used that motion. You are welcome
to go watch it. I have referenced it on my Twitter. You can go
check that out. It is a direct link to the timestamp and then
you can go back and look in context. >> Oh, is it really?
I didn't see the YouTube time stamp. >> Most of you watching
this know me from my relative. >> That wasn't timestamped.
That wasn't timestamped at all. Oh, 518 though, >> Realized
it was the let's play part of it that was the problem. Continuing
down the let's play path, I decided to just >> I don't
know why you would do that. That's not a Nazi salute, but why
the are you doing that? Why?
You're just
he's not throwing up a Roman even. That's the sad thing. Okay.
If this was like coded, if this was like a dog whistle, I would
be I would think it's funny. I would think it's funny for sure,
but it's not a dog whistle. He's actually just trying to point
in a >> Add our play part of it. That was the problem.
Continuing down the let's >> continuing down the let's
play path. See, this is not this is not a salute. Okay. Nah.
Nah. Nah, nah. He's fine. He's just >> let's play path.
I decided to just add Ark Survival to the mix. It was my first
time playing through Ark ever, and I figured just that in and
of itself, with as old as the game was at the time, would bring
extra people in. After that didn't work, I walked it back and
started creating challenge videos in 7 Days to Die. My first
attempt at one of those received 10 times the video views that
any of my previous
>> Oh, Babby's first video, >> let's play videos.
I also randomly found myself getting the itch to play a competitive
hero again. After trying Apex Legends again, I found that the
game was still in the god-awful place that I had left it. So,
I started to branch out and ultimately ended up trying Overwatch
2. Obviously, we know how that worked out, but there's more details
to share.
I'm going to go with catastrophically is how that worked out
>> that you probably don't know. My initial placements
were in season 1 and I placed
>> Oh, season one of Overwatch 2. Season one of Overwatch
2 >> five on both damage and support. It wouldn't be until
season 2 that I would place in silver 4 on tank. Now getting
to the beginning of 2023. I'm still a full-time content creator.
I continue. Is he actually a content creator or a want to be?
Both. He does make full-time content or he did for a while and
then he's like gone in and out of it. And he does make a decent
amount of content. So he's he's got like some money coming in.
I don't know if he's quite a hobbyist. He's probably a little
beyond a hobbyist. continued live streaming 7 Days to Die and
Overwatch 2, eventually swapping that Seven Days to Die content
out for Star Citizen. I then realized that most of the successful
content, >> okay, there's there's where we get to the bad
financial decisions from his past. Okay, some Star Citizen talked
about how he made some really bad financial decisions and it
didn't work out. I'm seeing
Christopher Is it Christopher Roberts? Is it Roberts?
You've ruined another family, sir. >> Creators I knew at
the time were creating in one game, so I decided to do the same.
I ended up choosing Overwatch 2 because I truly loved and still
love the game more than I have loved any other game I've played.
At the time, I was hooked on this series on Tik Tok from a guy
named Jordan that took an ice bath every single day. Inspired
by his series, I started considering how I could take that daily
concept and mesh it with my love for Overwatch. What I enjoy
most about the Overwatch 2 experience is the competitive nature
of the game. I decided to lean into that and started documenting
my journey in May to competing in the Overwatch League. I started
as a support main and a Baptist one trick. Then just as I'm gaining
momentum, the Overwatch League disbanded in October.
I honestly lost a lot of motivation, started to doubt my journey,
and considered exploring a new
>> Dude, they they saw his video about making it an Overwatch
League. Okay, they saw his like his his first video about it,
and they're like, "We got to shut this down. This is doing way
too much harm to society right now. Okay, this is unacceptable.
We're disbanding Overwatch League. Goodbye, everybody." >> Game
to pursue professionally. Now, we get to this year. In January,
the Overwatch Champion series was announced. I took a huge breath
of relief because I >> Oh, I didn't realize he was talking.
Wait, 2018, 2019, 2020. He's been making a He's been making content
for a long >> Truly still loved and still love Overwatch
2. I didn't want to walk away from it. It was around the same
time that the OWCS started that I decided to walk away from support
and try to be a tank player instead. The reason I did that is
that tank for me was much more challenging than support was,
and I am in this for the challenge. During this time, I have
continued creating content part-time with the intent of building
a 12month emergency fund so that I don't actually have to stop
being a full-time creator ever again. Now that you've learned
about the story so far, if you want to know what the future is
looking like and how I'm going to get there, you can check out
this video right here where I detail the road map that I have
>> Okay. Well, we watched the the rest of this. Oh, yeah.
I do I do like that we got the timeline there of his old content.
Okay. I'm glad he he brought that up with us. Go back to the
lo video. Nazi. He's not a Nazi. He didn't do a salute, guys.
KKK member. Wait, he's not a KKK member. He's not. Or is he?
I don't know. Realistically, I should probably look for where
these allegations are being made independently. I think they're
all they're most likely just from trolls, but I don't know. That
that hand argument was kind of weird. >> I was discussing
the fact that I was kind of using the motion to project the future.
had nothing to do with Nazi Germany. And the fact that so many
people bought into that showed the collective IQ of the internet.
It was insane. And seriously, if you're offended by the fact
that I just called you stupid,
people just want a new DSP, don't they? More than anything in
the world. They just want a new DSP. They think this is the guy.
Wait, hold on. What is Sleep Token? Please tell me this not Okay,
it's a band. Oh, it's a band. I didn't know it was a band. I
didn't know it was a band.
Oh, thank god it's a band. For a second I I saw like Oh, for
a second. Oh, thank God. Thank Christ. Unironically, I thought
it was crypto. I thought it was crypto. I was going to lose I
was going to lose my I thought it was a cryptocurrency. I thought
it was a cryptocurrency and he was talking about making bad financial
decisions. Okay, >> I'm sorry. Not trying to offend you,
but at the same time, please use your brain. That on its own
was really not as big of a thing for me that I was concerned
about. But then there were a couple of other coincidences that
I'm getting into now that kind of tied in with it and unfortunately
started to provide each other validity to a lot of people. This
one I kind of understood why people saw it after it was explained
to me. My old Patreon tears used to be starting with the letter
K and there were three of them. So people kind of associated
KKK. Now if it was just normal words that started with the letter
K, I could understand why people would be reading into way too
much. But the word contributor, which was one of the tiers for
instance, starts with the letter C, but I spelled it with a K.
The word nobility starts with the letter N, but I added the silent
K at the beginning. The word crusader, crusader and contributor,
I think I already said contributor. Both of those words start
with the letter C, and I used the K. Now, the reason for that
is my community is referred to as the kinship, as in a brother
and sisterhood. The reason I used the word kinship, by the way,
is because it is a genderneutral term. So, I used that, went
forward with it, and decided I wanted to try and brand around
the idea of using the letter K to keep things consistent. It
never even occurred to me that people would read into that to
that depth. But unfortunately, the thing that compounded it that
I wasn't told until significantly later is that my logo over
the top of a shield was very similar to some KKK
iconography back in >> this logo kind of doesn't suck.
It's like a fist and a G at the same time. Gaming G for hope
>> in the day. A simple history Google >> He's jerking
off across. It kind of looks like he's jerking off across. Okay.
It's a little weird. It's a little It's a little weird. Yeah,
it's a little >> Search would have taught me that, but
it's not something that I ever really would have thought about
because in fairness, I'm not part of the KKK. However, those
things combined with the Nazi salute and people just immediately
assumed that I was a white supremacist, that I'm a racist. And
I can understand why you would be concerned by the the combination
of those three things. But to jump to those radical conclusions
is where I'm kind of like, you guys need to stop spending so
much time on the internet and actually go touch some grass. I'm
going to be honest with you. So, to be clear and to recap so
far, I want to be very clear. I am not a Nazi. I'm not a member
of the KKK. It's so wild that I even have to say this out loud.
I do not hate you if you are part of the >> I don't know
why. Why are they all K's
I >> the LGBTQIA plus community. I do not neglect my children
keeping up with me so far. Let's talk about the job situation.
First of all, let's just make it a very TLDDR at the beginning.
I'm employed. That probably solves it for a lot of you. But for
the rest of you that are curious about what happened, I'm going
to share the story. >> Are you still with Uber and Lift
though? I That was crazy where he's like, I'm employed. I drive
for Uber. >> It's like, well, technically, yeah, but Ortobella,
thank you for the 18 months. Let's go. Oh, I should chill real
quick. I don't know if we're going to do more content after this.
I've got I've got the TechTome video. I don't know if I'm going to
do it in the next hour, but we'll see. We've got other stuff
as well. Guys, if you like the content, go ahead, throw a couple
subs. I think we are what, eight subs away from another hour
on the stream. Okay, eight subs or any amount of donations going
up to 40 bucks. Up to you guys. We'll get through this no matter
what. All right, this is short. Same guy and funny as Hold on.
>> Back Star. >> New ship in Star Citizen. Oh, new
ship in Star Citizen versus kids college fund. No.
>> Backst Star Citizen raises family. Kids go to college.
Star Citizens come out. >> Kids didn't go to college so
I could play Star Citizen. >> Sorry kids, but I had priorities.
>> You can either eat this week or I buy a new ship. >> Uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
Really? Really, Perry? Really? this. Get him the out of here.
I'm banning this guy from my Discord right now. Get him the out
>> because I do think it bears relevance and I believe
because I've been so transparent about the situation financially
and have asked for help in the recent past. >> He uh he
sent me that thumbnail.
>> I need to be transparent. Back in November of last year,
I did leave the teller job that I referenced in my OWCS roadmap
video. I left that job not because we were finally at the goals
that I was trying to achieve at the time, which was to have a
six-month emergency fund and our debts completely paid off, but
because >> you were depressed.
He was depressed. He was depressed. >> As I had been denied
a promotion that I was promised from the beginning for the fourth
time in a row, despite having every metric checked and then some.
My manager continued to move the goalpost and say, "Well, you
need to do this now. Well, you need to do this now. Well, you
need to do this now." I needed the raise that came with that
to continue to support my family at a high level. I realized
I could go make better money than even the promotion running
share. So that's exactly what I did. So I was gainfully employed
from the moment I left the teller job, just to be super clear.
And then life happened. December 30th, I believe, I got into
the car accident with the vehicle that I was using primarily
to do the ride share stuff. It totaled the vehicle. And because
I had only been doing it for about a month, I couldn't go get
a new auto loan. So I'm like, well, crud. Now I'm in a pickle.
We have one car, >> dude. No way. Uh, so wait, he didn't
have insurance on this vehicle? No. No insurance. The vehicle's
totaled. He can't get a new vehicle at all. >> We are about
to have, as a matter of fact, we had already had >> my
third >> your third kid. Yeah. >> And we were just,
we had two sedans. We were two cars everywhere we went. >> And
now we're down to one car that can't fit all of our family. So
now I'm in a pickle. I start driving that car around for ride
share and then it throws a check engine light that was critical.
You cannot drive it. It was a flashing check engine light. So
I pulled it over and we took it to the shop and I couldn't drive
it anymore. So now what do I do? In essence, we still had some
>> Bro, God is this guy. What did this guy Dude, you're
devout. How How do you get over that where like everything is
going wrong? What are these challenges?
Why? What? I feel like I sort of when I get this many like down
things in a row, I start to personally go like I'm not getting
the whole story
right. How many how many crazy like bad things in a row can happen
to somebody that it like you kind of stop believing it, right?
Maybe you didn't have full coverage. I just like everything's
gone wrong all in a row here
and it all points to him becoming like a full-time content creator
again. I just feel like something something's getting fudged.
gay. We're fudging the story a little bit somewhere. No, losing
the vehicle in the ride shirt like an accident. That makes sense.
Okay, that's not covered. Sure. But now the second video, the
second vehicle's gone. And in a previous video, he also said
like I was depressed about the teller job. I wasn't enjoying
myself, so I started doing content creation again. So, I don't
know where these are all going together. >> Is an emergency.
And I'm like, you know what? The content seems to be picking
up a little bit. What if I just hit the gas pedal a little bit?
So, I talked to my wonderful bride and I was like, "Look, if
you want me to go get another job right now, I'll go do it."
Not hesitating one time. >> Dude, you know what? This guy
sabotaged the engine so you get back into Overwatch. Okay. Do
you guys see it? I can't be the only one who sees it. That like
literally up this car and he's like, "You know what, babe? Babe,
I should just try content creation again." Okay. Hit the gas
pedal is crazy. It is a little crazy.
That's putting insane juju on his content creation uh career
given everything else he said
about him driving. Okay. I think God is telling me to play Overwatch.
Yeah, exactly. If you really want me to go get another job, I
will. But, you know, I could just try content creation again.
That's always an option. However, if you're cool with me taking
a little bit of a risk for the next couple months, I'd like to.
And she was completely okay with it. And by the way, that's how
marriage works. Communication. If she had said, "I'm not cool
with it." the end of the day, again, for me as a Christian, I'm
gonna die to myself and what I want to do.
>> Is that true, though? If if your wife says, "No, no,
no, that's not okay." Are you really good with it or are you
like, is there a reason she sort of I can't say for sure. I'm
going to say I don't have the information to know. But when somebody
tells me like, "That's how it works, I ask for the thing I need,
and then when they say yes, that means they're totally happy
with it." I don't think that's how a lot of communication works.
Yeah. Did she even have a That's like she probably had a choice,
but I don't know that she'd be happy about it, right? That's
more the question. He's like, "Yeah, my beautiful wife was more
than happy to do." It's like, "Was she though? Was she though?"
>> In order to serve and love my wife. That is what I'm
called to do as a Christian dude. Period. End of story. Well,
because our emergency fund had dried up after that little stint
of doing my best to gear everything up and I didn't have any
real revenue coming in that was allowing me to support my family
even at the low level of our bills at the time. It was time for
me to get a job. So, I did. Didn't hesitate. Soon as >> Oh,
okay. Well, burning through that emergency fund again and immediately
>> The moment hit that I realized I was like, well, we're
cooked if I don't go get a job. I went and got a job. My family
comes first. And anybody who has watched my stream for more than
maybe 30
>> My family comes first. I ran through all of our emergency
fund and at the very last moment I went to try to get work. What
would have happened if I couldn't find employment? Well, sometimes
you just got to risk these things and let God decide. Okay, >> 45
minutes knows that I still want to be a full-time content creator
in the in the grand scheme of things. The competitive stuff is
a short-term goal of mine and if I fail, I fail. A lot of people
think that I'm so delusional that I think that I will not I have
no chance of failure. I have a very high chance of failure. But
I'm willing to fail. I don't care. Failure is part of how you
learn and grow in your life if you consistently stay inside your
comfort. Yeah. But if I'm like if I'm trying to like juggle knives,
right? Failure might not be the best way to learn. Sometimes
there are like risks to the things you attempt to do, right?
And if you're not equipped to do them, I can't just go and juggle
chainsaws. Okay? I can't do it. I'll die. You going to play Overwatch
is like that. Like you're going to juggle chainsaws. You haven't
you haven't picked an appropriate task that your skills are equipped
for at all. It's like you could say you want to do that, but
basically I don't know, bro. You're
h
I don't think it's I just don't think it's working right. Like
there are major downsides to this he's trying to learn to do
and trying to figure out. There's just there's downsides to taking
the time out of his life to do this and he's not really properly
evaluating the the possibility of success. Is just not his target
audience. I don't know who his target audience is. I could see
the Star Citizen maybe he could make content. He's not like totally
unentertaining.
It's possible he could make some content, but I I just don't
get the the obsession with Overwatch at all. Like pick a game.
Like realistically as a responsible father trying to be a content
creator, I feel like the angle to take would have been whatever
the popular content was, right? Not necessarily Overwatch, but
like hey rivals or whatever the zone >> could have been
good. >> You will never grow. I am willing to push myself
outside of it and fail in the worst case scenario. All right,
let's talk about the accusations of me grooming my wife. Wild
that people think that is actually a thing that happened.
>> 14 subs for 2 hours or just one? Um, no. Eight subs
for two hours. No, sorry. Eight subs for one hour. Eight subs
for one hour. Eight subs for one hour is >> on May 7th,
2019, I posted a video about pleasing your spouse. How to essentially
take care of your spouse and love on them. It's not a thing.
Don't get weird. >> Why did you say it that way? So 16
for two, it would be 17 for two. If you want to do two, be 17
for two. >> I referred to my wife at the time, and a lot
of you assumed that I was referring to my current wife, Rachel.
Uh, many of you don't know this because I don't talk about it
a lot. I've been married one other time. >> You're talking
about how to pleasure your other significant other. Okay. >> she
cheated, so I left because I don't put up with that crap,
How did this guy How did this guy find a new woman and get married
again and have kids? What is wrong with us? >> That's the
end of it. I was married before. That was who I was referring
to in that video, but I don't have any reason to remove that
video because it was still some valid advice. Fast forward to
now. And of course, it wasn't Rachel that I was talking about.
I didn't even know Rachel then. While I don't expect you to think
that I was married before or be able to figure that out, I would
like to think that the collective idea of the internet would
be capable of figuring out >> that maybe there's a better
>> Hold on. Spruce Willis, thank you for the gifted sub.
And hey, hey, dance, thank you for the 10 gifted
>> huge 10 gifties. Thank you very much. Let's go. Let's
That is another hour on the stream. And beyond that,
nine uh we should have three subs. So, six subs for another hour
on the stream, we'll say. Uh let's see here. I should add the
houroop
123. There you go. >> Hour on the stream and three. Sorry,
six more for another hour. Thank you very >> And then I
groomed my wife. Come on now. Seriously. All right. Now, for
the moment that many of you have probably clicked to, to be honest
with you, and it's not really a reaction to Apply's >> Okay,
we'll just put the other hour on the stream. I'm sure somebody
will roll a sub over or something. >> This would be just
be easier. There we go. Now, focus on my response. Let's go.
>> For those that don't know, I highly encourage you to
go watch it. It was a great video. And don't take what he says
personally at the beginning. It was for content and humor. I'm
sure there was some truth and validity to what he actually felt.
>> Responding to Apply's video that was this one that we
had up. We don't have it here anymore. Right-wing lunatic, thank
you for the gifted sub. Let's go. Let's check this out. Right-wing
lunatic. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I think that's this
guy, right? This guy was apply to wrap up. >> This was
apply. Okay. This guy was kind of talking. I'm saying you you
suck. Give it up. >> Put together. >> Not this video.
Not this video, not this video,
but this video. >> But it was very well put together. I
thought it was a little crude. Sure. A little brass. Sure. But
it was humor. And then he did a VOD review of my Doomfist gameplay,
which you know what? I'm glad he did that even though I'm not
a Doomfist player. I'll get to that in a minute. But obviously
for those of you that watch my content, you know I'm not a Doomfist
player. Those were the only games that I have on Doomfist are
posted and he reviewed the last one in there. I do want to give
him some credit for that. By the way, he skipped to the last
game of the 10, presuming that I would have learned the most
by that point, which is an accurate assumption. It was a terrible
game for many reasons. Pro Overwatch. This is the first one.
>> 2026 is my uh ultimate >> Oh, no. This I see.
No, this is the video we watched. I just skipped through some
of his uh review of the first
>> Okay, never mind. Never mind. But that is the guy we
watch some of his >> big one we're going to get to now.
I really needed to swallow a very difficult pill when he pointed
out that my blaming my teammates was probably my big No, it was
my biggest problem. I'm not going to screw around it. It was
my biggest problem. Not only was it my biggest problem, it is
still currently my biggest problem.
>> And it's interesting because I always tell you guys
mindset is everything. But for some reason, I allowed myself
to have this blind spot for way too long.
>> Dude, yeah, you you have to be zen in these games, okay?
You have to
you have to enter the void, okay? You cannot have emotion.
You cannot be hateful, okay? You can't do it. You enter the void.
If you want to do your best, be unshakable. You can't go in on
your team. You only make things worse. You never screamed at
somebody in your team and made things better. Okay? Ever. Ever.
Ever. Have been in crude ways pointing it out in my comments
for a while. You need to quit blaming your teammates and just
focus on you. And it took me until today actually. I was listening
to an audio book. U you'll have to excuse the phrase editor.
Please censor this. Um, but this the title is literally The Subtle
Art of Not Giving a >> This is one of the worst books ever
written. What's the guy's name? Something Manson.
This is the one of the worst books ever written. The suble art
of not giving a Mark Manson. This video, this book is complete
dog. I had to listen to this audio book driving like 15 hours
for a job fair that I agreed to go to with two HR women from
my company. I had to drive 15 hours to this job fair and they
wanted to listen to this book and this book sucked.
This book
sucked. I fell asleep. Okay. But for the hour I listened, holy
sh this was garbage. Okay. Yeah. The subtle art of not giving
a this guy Mark Manson. He wrote a follow-up book. Mark Manson
books. Everything is he wrote the subtle art of not giving a
and then followed that up with everything is this
hate this guy. >> That book
talks about the importance of taking radical responsibility for
everything that happens to you. >> Uh how to win friends
and influence people is good and Cy is wrong. And even though
even though Desty recommends it, the the book sounds mavelian.
The book is literally, hey, if you um if you are like invested
in other people and you give them your energy with no ask in
return, they will remember that and and like you as a person.
And if you like take if you take a deep interest in people, if
you make them a like a a core part of your experience in your
life, they'll notice that and they'll care about you. Most people
cannot read that book. Every everybody I've ever told reads that
that I've read that book to, they think it sounds Mchavelian.
I'm like, dude, it's literally just telling you how to be like
nice. It's it's literally Yeah. Yeah. 50 Laws of Power is Mchuellian.
How to win friends and influence people is like, yeah, it's literally
like, yeah, if you remember people's names, they'll think you're
like a good person. They'll think they matter to you, right?
If you if you find ways to show people they matter, that you've
been watching them and you know they're better at something.
This is where the compliment thing, I don't know if I talked
about the compliment thing on stream, but like uh I just learned
how to give good compliments and it was like really um it was
really helpful in a corporate environment, right? You give people
a compliment that they can't refute. It's literally like I've
watched you, you said you wanted to to do this thing, right?
You said you wanted to, you had a goal of doing this thing. I
watched you put in like this work and that work and that work
and now you've gotten to that goal and congratulations. You look
really awesome now that you got to that goal, right? You just
say facts. You figure out how to give them facts that are compliments
on the things they've actually put work into instead of just
saying you're really out there, right? Yeah. Zanakali knows exactly.
And people just love that. It's awesome. It's so good. But yeah,
but it's it's literally like not machavelian at all because you
actually have to put work in and care about people. That's like
literally what it tells you. If you put work in and care about
people, if you make them like something important to your life,
they will reciprocate. It's just a natural human reaction. Just
seems weird that people need a book for that. Well, I think people
can do that, but they
they just lose sight of it sometimes. And you read the book and
it like kind of kicks in. It's very good >> in your life.
And this is something that a lot of you have tried and even Awkward
has mentioned in content that I've seen from him. He's very big
on that. It's one of the biggest things that he talks about.
Taking accountability for your gameplay or for your life in general.
It doesn't matter what circumstances hit you. Of course, you
can't be at fault for all of your circumstances, but you can
take >> You say the name again. How to win friends and
influence people. It's a really old book. Mark Carnegie. I've
read it once. I think I was going to read it a second time. I
should probably read it a second time, but I've read I read the
whole thing once. It was very helpful
for work, I would say. Like you don't I don't know if you think
about work relationships in quite the same way as like personal
relationships, right? But I'd say like the idea that you could
do it for a work relationship and that it was like somebody's
key to like sales was a really really Dale Carnegie. Whoops.
I don't know why I said Mark Carnegie. Mark Manson maybe. Yeah,
Dale Carnegie. Radical Cander would be another one. No, Radical
Cander is garbage.
I hate Radical Cander. I hate that book. I hate that book. Okay.
Most of the books from like that 2018 to like 2022 era, I read
like all of those books and I have opinions on all of those books.
Any book that like a manager would have read in that era, I read
it. I have strong opinions. Okay.
The Oh, that radical cander book is garbage.
I hate that book. Anyway, >> take responsibility for how
you receive them and how you respond to them. So, are some games
losses that were not my fault? Sure. But that doesn't matter
is the point. I can only take responsibility for what I can control.
And at the end of the day, the valid point that many people have
made is that if I can't solo carry a platinum game, or in the
case of the Doomfist video, I think it was bronze and silver
games.
>> Oh no, he wasing bronze and silver with
>> I'm nowhere near OWCS, which by the way, I know I'm
not ignorant to that, but it was a good point. I justified the
soft blaming of my teammates for way too long. And what I mean
by that is that I didn't outright cuss them out or flame them
or get angry and slam my desk like the majority of very popular
content creators do across the space. This isn't just an Overwatch
issue. People love rage bait. >> Oh, please tell me he
did not just utter under his breath that these people suck. That's
so much worse. That's so much >> these days.
Because I didn't do it in a mean way. I justified it. That is
on me. The way that I got into high diamond and eventually low
masters on support despite rank inflation was that I had that
self-accountability concept down to a science. There was not
one mistake that I made that I didn't own and specifically call
out when I made it. We're getting back to that. This was something
I first heard from awkward when I was watching his one trick
Baptiste unranked the GM when I was learning Baptiste myself.
I am fully owning and apologizing for my poor attitude when it
comes to my teammates and not accepting responsibility for my
>> This guy's a big guy. That's a that's a big man right
there. Okay. >> Because anything else is a waste of time
and I don't have a lot of it and I got to get a grip. Let's talk
about the goal calibration here. Uh obviously
apply kind of had a goofy interpretation of the iconography that
I used for the timeline. I had a really good laugh at that because
the way he explained it, if that's how I really thought that
was very backwards.
So, in the road map, he's going to get money. Well, he's going
to get signed. Oh, no. He hits Masters,
gets signed, makes money,
wins a championship, and then hits GM.
So, we're going to win a championship, and then we're going to
hit GM. All right, that's that's a good [__] plan.
I'm going to read them off cuz I'll forget, but it was hit masters,
join a scrim team, build financial stability with my job, participate
in tournaments with my team, hit top 25 tanks NA, and push for
the OWCS. While
>> these goals are not actually bad, nor do I think the
order of them is awful. I do think there's some real criticism
that I need to accept and adapt to a little bit and share the
kind of clear to hear it >> the first and share the kind
of clearer plan that's in my head. Additionally, I'm going to
keep it specific to Overwatch and leave my personal life out
of it because uh too many of you are not mature enough to hear
it. The first step in this new concept is to join a scrim team
simultaneously while pushing towards masters. That's going to
take me a while. I'm cool with that. I don't have a lot of time
in the game because my family is my priority
and content's right behind it. Competiting competiting competing
is my third priority in the context of what I'm talking about
right now. This is like maybe you could say this is fine in that
as long as he's really not putting like a ton of extra
effort into that like maybe it's fine but like why why not just
say like a much more realistic goal that probably doesn't get
any clicks so maybe it's fine right is just he wants to be like
GM just say I want to be GM I just want to be GM right but he
says he wants to be in like the OWCS and it's like he's clearly
can't put the effort in to do it so he just sounds
that's but again Maybe maybe there's a strategy to get clicks.
So maybe >> after I hit masters, the goal is then big surprise
to hit grand masters and then eventually push for the top 25
tanks NA. I do understand that just being in I believe it's masters
one puts you in the top 500 tanks in NA, but I don't want to
settle for that. I want to push for the very best I can go for.
And then I want to compete in the OWCS regardless of where I
place. If I don't place in the top 50 teams, I still completed
the goal of doing something that people told me that I couldn't
do. so that I can prove to you, the people watching on the other
side of this, the audience, people who actually like my content,
you can do anything you set your mind to. Screw people who don't
agree with you. From the point at which I've competed in the
OWCS, if things go as well as I hope they do, maybe I'll continue
competing. But either way, content is what I wanted to use to
support my family because again, something I'm aware of, uh,
esports doesn't really make much money, particularly unless you're
playing like the top three titles over >> Oh, I am ADHD
as right now. Okay. I clicked off of this. So, I went to go see
something on kick.
I just like H on the front page.
H on the front page and he's just like death staring into the
camera, charging into battle. He's so cool sometimes.
Wish Wish I saw content anywhere with this guy in it, but charging
into battle. Let's go. >> Overwatch is not one of those,
unfortunately. So, I got to do something else to support the
fans. >> Yes, we are. traditional job is I'm tired of working
for other people because it sucks. I mean, let's all be honest
on that one. So, I'm going to create content while I compete
and that means I got to hire editors and all that fun stuff.
I understand all these things. Too many people think that I'm
just head in the clouds, never going to come down. Man, if you
just talk to me for like 30 minutes, you might find out I'm not
so unreasonable of a guy. In conclusion of all of this, I want
to share something with you because this is very important. >> Very
reasonable guy. He's going to be an Overwatch pro while also
raising his family of four now, five, three kids and his wife.
>> Please do yourself and me a favor and be more aware
of what you're doing on the internet. All of this video and all
of the BS and drama we've all had to endure for the last little
while could have been avoided if I had been a little bit better
number one at communicating. That's the big one. Number two,
if the community that posted and shared these content pieces
had actually bothered to do just a little bit of research, they
would have known that it wasn't true and it would have stopped
it there. And at the third fail safe, those of you in the community
that bought into what you saw, didn't share it, but bought into
it silently
without researching, you got to take some responsibility, too.
I want to be clear. >> I don't know if those people care,
bro. I think those people are with you. >> You don't have
to agree with anything I say. I know that there's some hatred
towards my political views, my religious views, and that's fine.
You are welcome to hate my views. I may not like yours either.
We should still be able to exist together kindly. I don't think
that's too much to ask. And if it is, it says more about you
than it does about me. >> I also want to encourage you
to most people don't do these days. >> Reach out to people
that you're like, you know, I've done my research. I can't really
figure out whether or not what I'm seeing is real. If you actually
are going to either perpetuate it or believe it yourself, it
would behoove you to reach out to the person that is being accused
of whatever it is and just ask. Have a real conversation. Some
people aren't like me and won't sit down and have a Discord call
with you like I've done with a handful of people over the last
couple of days, but others man. Okay, I get that this guy is
probably going to be a lowc.
This video is not quite as bad as some other people made it out
to be. It is bad, but I like if you think of it as like a marketing
ploy, it would depend on what his hour split really is, right?
If he really is only doing like an hour a day of Overwatch,
is it not just like a clear marketing ploy and he's just using
all of this to make himself like look kind of and he's just trying
to hope like build views off of it? People said that this was
like really like he's totally delusional. He's a total allcow,
but like I would understand that if he was talking about like,
oh, I'm spending all my time with my family or sorry, playing
Overwatch, but he's like clearly not putting the amount of time
in Overwatch he needs to. He's either like delusional and lost
it and spending a bunch of time around doing nothing or he's
like kind of just doing a marketing ploy. Yeah, I don't know.
I want to I kind of want to see more now. >> Will sit down
with you and do just that or at least respond to your message.
At the end of the day, some people that watch this will change
nothing about their views of me. And that's up to you, man. I
>> Noah Tannon bomb. What did you just say? What the did
what you just say mean? What you just said mean? What did that
mean? What is that?
Do not talk about something degenerate. My chat. Okay. >> Can't
control your >> Watch the live stream of his mom. Link
the live stream of his mom right now. Link it. Someone link it.
>> Thoughts on me and I frankly don't care. That's that's
on you. I've done my best to at least give people that actually
care the knowledge and clarification of where I stand with all
of these things so that you can be aware of it and decide what
you want to do with the information yourself. But some people
at the end of the day truly just want to hate on someone that
they don't understand. The amount of replies and comments that
I've seen in the last couple of days that have been strongly
to the effect of no, I don't believe anything that's being spread
around him about about him right now. But you've got to admit
there's got to be something wrong with him. He's too kind. is
too gracious, is too whatever positive thing. The fact that the
world today is so thrown off by someone who's just being kind
generally, again, I'm not without my flaws. I'm not without
But the fact that I stand out that heavily and the response is
not, "Wow, he's actually kind to people. That's wild." It's there's
got to >> That's crazy. >> Again, that's about society
as a whole than it does about me. I wanted to say a huge thank
you to a couple of people who I know for a fact have spoken out
against the whole situation happening. Uh the number one person
that comes to my brain is Spoil. I don't know if he was first.
That's not really my point. But he was one of the more prominent
figures that was jumping on the Hey, I think that while you may
not agree with him, and I'm not asking you to agree with him
on things, I think that the >> Well, he said that about
himself. Well, no, he's saying other people are saying it about
him. believe he put it as schoolyard bullying in his tweet. That's
a very apt description.
I am baffled that he let alone took the time to post that, but
he actually DM'd me. I won't share what he DM'd, but I will tell
you it was a very nice sentiment. It was a very check-in more
or less what it boiled down to. Spoiler is truly one of the most
wholesome creators that the Overwatch community has. And the
fact that you haters out there of him have not scared him off
really says a lot about him. He's a great guy from what I've
been able to tell. I really spy. >> Gosh, I hope I get
to meet him some point. He's just such a cool dude. Another one
I do want to shout out as well is I I hope I'm saying your name
right. I don't know that I've ever actually heard anybody say
your name cuz I don't watch a lot of content these days, but
uh I'm going to call you Derpy. I hope that's right. And we've
talked about this on stream and I think you've told me that's
how it is. But I don't know. Derpy has been very supportive of
my content. So much so that he's even raided my stream a couple
of times. He did a watch party during my scrim and that led to
a huge spike in growth for me. I'm immensely grateful for that.
And he also spoke out against this. He retweeted what Spilo posted
and shared his own thoughts. >> And these are the only
two creators that I know of off the top of my head that have
spoken out against this. But I got to tell you, in the midst
of all of the BS that I've had, I have learned one thing again,
remembered, learned, however you want to put that. You can either
let life's circumstances
make you a victim, or you can choose to take life's circumstances
by the horns
and fix it. And that's where I'm at right now. I'm owning my
mistakes,
taking life's circumstances by the horns, and I'm going to fix
some things. Let's go. W Gaming for Hope. All right. Oh. Oh,
man. I was going to go on. Oh, I was going to go on to this guy's
mom content or something else, but I just saw a Rev says Desu.
Rev says Desu clip. Is he going to soy the out over denims?
There's no way he'll soy out over denims. Is there the denims
content? There's no way. There's no way that the guy who has
a lolly body pillow in his shop would soy out about denims
showing a little skin to pay her legal bills. There's no way.
Check out the Wild Ring camera video I sent in your Discord.
What is it? What is it?
What is it? Content suggestions.
Oh, I've seen this. I don't know if I can show it on stream though.
It is interesting, but I don't know if I can see it if I can
watch it on stream.
Uh, Plantad, we watched the Oh.
Oh [__] Oh my god. Darius got his big break. Oh,
I didn't realize where this was from. Atosi is covering uh Darius
content.
>> Atosi is covering Darius content. Unfortunately, that
means he will actually be in jail soon. But if a Tozi is covering
you, yeah, you up. Okay. You're annoying.
You're really annoying.
Let's go.
Just got arrested. That's funny. Sorry. I was like, Plantad,
why did you link me this? I watched all of this. You watched
me watch all of this. >> These kick streamers just got
arrested on [__] >> But it's an Atosi video.
That's pretty big deal. 100,000 views in three hours. By the
way, this guy gets massive views if you guys are unaware. Okay,
Atosi. Massive, massive views. Hundreds of thousands of views
for every video. What did they burgle? Like eight Gatorades or
something. Like eight Gatorades. Eight whole Gatorades. Okay,
they got eight whole Gatorades and they're going to jail for
it. I think Darius also assaulted Mark technically. So, okay.
Hey, what's up? So, you've been following me. >> I almost
want to watch the Asmin Gold reaction.
There's got to be an Asmin Gold reaction, too, right? Do we just
watch these people like soy the out over nothing? Let me go to
Asmin TV. Let's see if there's a Denim's reaction. >> Anonymous
just tipped $5. Have you tried Death Stranding 2? >> Never
tried Death Stranding one. So, no, I've not tried Death Stranding
2. No as gold video on the denim yet. Unfortunate
techone video. Tech video on the denim. The response was diabolical.
Women be crazy. This got to be over denims, right? Nope. Nope.
Nope. Nope. Hold on. Would he not have addressed it today? No.
You soy.
>> Okay. Nope.
Too bad we just got wrapped on Twitter. You know why today was
such a mess. And we're dealing with stuff that I probably will
address tomorrow. But anyways,
today we're talking about Hassan. Why are we talking about Hassan?
Well, because hating on Hassan is one of the most profitable
industries on the entire internet right now. Can you guys say
Hassan is bad?
Cuz that's what everyone else says all the time. >> It's
due to his affiliation with Lwig. Now Lwig is one of his biggest
>> Wait, what? >> Today we're talking about Hassan.
Why are we talking about Hassan? Well, it's due to his affiliation
with Lewig. Oh, what happened with Did Ledwig? Leedwig defended
somebody people their pants over. Assad is bad. Assad is bad.
Who did Who is Ledwig defending that people their pants over?
It looked so stupid. He had like Was it some comment? Was it
one of the people getting sued? Feel like he had some comment
defending people and and people are trying to >> Now Lwig
is one of his biggest defenders.
someone who
accidentally
criticized him a few months ago and Hassan said, "Hey,
fix your commentary about me." And Lwig complied and altered
his video. And after that said, >> Lwig is like a [__]
>> I'll never make drama videos again. Now recently Lwig
has been a lot of controversy uh mainly involving this event
right here. His burial cart event that he hosted where this was
a drinking event where he invited an individual at >> Okay,
I do not care one iota, one single iota
about his lewig commentary. >> Out of his way.
>> I don't I I literally don't care. Shauna Black crashes
out at Lewig for blaming creator crash. Creator Clash 3's failure
on the content cop.
Oh,
dude, it's so boring. It's so boring.
Does that really matter? I'll I'll watch it. I'll watch it after
the mango stuff. We don't need the mango [__] But
of >> Creator Clash 3 was ending. Apparently, Lwig blamed
it on the content cop. Of course, a lot of people were very angry
about his mild take on this situation. So, another account uh
posted
basically the the same clip we just saw and Sean Dlac,
don't worry guys, I'm Rev. Dwight. Uh, he said, "I have a lot
of thoughts on this being a Lud watcher, but for now, I'll stick
to just expressing how disappointing this is. Don't worry, Sean
the Black express his opinion a couple months ago." Why would
you not talk about the people try and this is crazy. This would
not apply to anywhere else.
This would not apply anywhere else.
Anywhere else. Only applies to Ethan. even is the only person
who gets a pass for his own admission
a charity event.
>> I think the over the obsession on like creator clash
and like uh it's like so transparently just like marketing, right?
I just don't get why you'd have to go after creator clash at
all. You're just with items in Ana. I I don't get why it was
like targeted at all. I really don't understand. I It feels weird.
It just feels really weird. gay. >> Why are we giving Ethan
a pass for >> I don't even know that you have to target
like I It's so weird. I don't know how else to describe it. How
many subs has he gained since Ethan is suing him?
Wait, Ethan Moody Morgan. Who is Ethan's not suing Shondaanda
Black? Are you He announced that that was fake like weeks ago.
Like a week ago more. What do you mean? >> He wants the
charity event to fail.
effectively getting the charity event to to fail and to postpone
is for the original creators to to divest from it. I feel like,
and this this is weird, right? I feel like that's [__]
a lot of people talk about. If any other creator made it their
mission to be like, "There's a charity event going on. I'm going
to torpedo it. I'm going to make it my mission to make sure that
event fails." I feel like that would be a little bit of of of
a of something that like people would talk about,
but no. For some reason, everyone is >> I think it was
weird to go after it. But I also think I thought if they if they
really had morals at all here. Okay. Oh, interesting. If um if
the Creator Clash people had morals, they would have taken Brandon
Buckingham's offer. Why didn't they take Brandon Buckingham's
offer? Right. I think he said, "Hey, I'll get Sam Hyde and some
of the boys. We'll we'll fill this whole event up." Well, everybody
wants to talk about how how how bad and mean Idubbbz is for responding
to Ethan Klein responding
implying that Ethan said first, which he
right? Pressuring his employee to drop out of the event and like
going out of his way to say that he wanted it to
But no, nobody talks about that. For some reason, the smoke is
only for Ian and Ana who is putting the event on in the first
place.
>> I'm not even saying you can't criticize them, but is
that not crazy? Is it not insane to cover a charity event failing?
I I think it's weird that Ethan did this.
I do think it's weird. Like, it's weird that Ethan was like,
"Oh, like you guys to the point I'll like actually start targeting
Creator Clash." But at the same time, I think Idubbd and Ana
probably were only putting Creator Clash on for their reputations.
So attacking Creator Clash is kind of in some ways equivalent
to attacking them, right? It's it's like it's not that far off.
I don't know. It's one of those places where like I'd probably
draw the line in the sand away from that. But I kind of understand
where they're coming from, where Ethan's coming from with that
one. and not talk about a millionaire with a million subscriber
channel with tens of thousands of concurrent viewers who is on
his live stream saying that he wants the event to fail. So, here
are some more quote retweets on that deleted post. Uh, this person
saying, "You hosted an event last week where you let a known
alcoholic
harass multiple women. I don't want to hear anything about PR
from you." Here's another one saying, "So why does he just kind
of keep having really weird comments recently? Like, bro, I'm
trying to have an open mind, but saying it's Ian's fault when
Ethan Klein is doing hate campaigns daily on the event and saying
we don't like the event because we are Hassan fans makes no sense."
Here's another one saying maybe someone that shut down their
live events company less than a year ago isn't the guy to tell
anyone about it. So, a lot of people are really upset, including
Hassan Orbiters, which is really funny because this guy tried
so desperately, Lwig tried so desperately to suck up to Hassan
and his Orbiters and his fans. And here's some more quotes on
the now suspended account that shared the original video.
This person saying, "Lwig is so tonedeaf and is not the good
guy that everyone makes him out to be. I'm genuinely so tired
of mfs like this getting respect from everyone." Here's another
one saying, "As a diehard Lwig fan, it's super disappointing
that he's a >> Oh, I so don't care. I so don't care. Get
to the denims thing. Holy [__] I will never understand
why someone can hate an online content creator this much, especially
one with deliberately inoffensive output. Oh, he actually called
like Lewig boring. Hey, >> where Hassan says I will never
clip. >> Dude, this is actually
Is this where all of Black's viewers went? Is this where um this
is Twitter versus now? Turns out if Boax didn't actually didn't
like publicly transition post pictures of himself in a dress,
if he just made an avatar that looked good in a dress, he could
have kept doing Twitter versus kept his entire audience, he would
have made so much money.
Oh my god. Why did he give it all up? He just gave it all up.
>> Expensive output. Uh, you know, let's see a clip of
this industry especially for an extended period of time. You're
just going to have a haters.
everyone's time comes inevitably. No one has actually stayed
above um no one like there are very few content creators on the
YouTube side or on the Twitch side especially that have basically
maintained like a level of prominence and a level of of of steady
love without any sort of haters whatsoever. I mean people hate
Lewig, dude. Think about that. This man is a [__]
golden retriever. He is mathematically
crafting takes that are the most like that are the most like
kind, empathetic, and and inoffensive you can possibly be, right?
And there are still people who despise this man. Think about
that. Think about how crazy that is. Um, some examples I will
give you of people who have uh who does don't have like a lot
of uh haters would be Markiplier on the YouTube side, Germa on
the Twitch side. This is like he's literally just he's literally
just taking he keeps calling Lewig boring. It's so funny. >> Northern
Line is another one. Uh and and maybe like Lyric, >> dude.
The man is a golden retriever mathematically crafting takes that
are the most kind, empathetic, and inoffensive. He's literally
explaining why Ludwig's so boring. This is funny as
>> right. And the calling out gets worse. >> Northern
Lion isn't inoffensive. Northern Lion's got a little attitude.
We have this person saying, "No one cares about your opinion,
Ethan. You're just a conservative." Now, let's see the conservative
opinion
of Ethan Klein, the liberal.
By the way, Sam Cedar has lost the last shred of dignity he had.
It's not that he had Hassan on. It's this pathetic photo of him
fawning over him. Bro, you're 58 years old, man. >> This
is like This is so embarrassing
for Ethan Klein. I realize that that's like a really overused
phrase. Okay, I'm going to ban this uh this person from my chat
now. Anime streamer person. Thank
this is just very funny to me that we keep saying, "Oh, this
is embarrassing for Ethan." Ethan just does a lot of embarrassing
like this just a picture that they took for their show, right?
It's just a picture they took. Why is he seething that other
people are like having a good time? How the do you just sit there
seething that other people are like happy? This is weirdly No,
this is his with Ana. Okay, that's the actual That is the actually
like weird creepy I don't know what the's going on. Why did you
just make that joke about going to a hotel room with Ana with
your wife who watches the show there? Why did you just do that,
Ethan? That's weird. Dan knows it's weird. We all know it's weird.
Oh, I I meant I was eye tubs actually. No, you didn't. No, you
didn't. >> Man, you look beathe This This photo is terrible.
No self-respecting man would make this photo. There's so many
jokes I can make. I'm going to hold him back cuz I'm going to
be the better person. Okay, I'm going to be the better person.
What is this, man? Anyways,
so there's some more. Dude, this was also a I don't know what
is this tweet. I saw this earlier today. This was like so angry.
I didn't get it at all. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
I'm going to read it with a soy voice. So, if you guys like a
I'm sorry.
Where the [__] is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where
is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Brother,
this guy tweets a lot.
Got to find it. I got to find it. Got to find it. Nope. Not that
one. Come on. I didn't go past. Oh, right here. There it is.
You are a law cow. No one needs your backing. That hurts way
more at this point than helps. Also, make sure to thank Night
Media next time. Never seeing you give them credit.
What? Why? Why are you seething? What did he say to make you
see so badly? You're like, if you are like me, a spoiled child
of America, and your focus after 20 months of live stream Holocaust
of children in Gaza is still in your personal feelings instead
of unconditional support for the victim to the victims of genocide,
there's more honor in continuing to stay quiet. Okay. On the
other hand, if you get over yourself and support Palestinian
emancipation, I and many others will welcome you with open arms.
Most of the liberal Zionists who either turned into kacist uh
kahanos
I don't know what I was trying to read there. Khan sickos anti-inists
or at least can read the room better and don't speak on it.
Okay. Yeah, sure.
I think I think this is unironically true. A bunch of people
stopped talking about it because they're like, "Oh, Israel actually
went sicko mode." Oh, I feel bad. I feel bad for sort of supporting
them at the beginning of this. They went sicko mode on those
Palestinians. They went absolutely sicko mode. I don't know what
the do now. I kind of said, "Yeah, what is what are they going
to do? Not defend themselves? They what do they just not defend
themselves?" And then and then uh and then they just went crazy.
They blew the whole thing up. Why were those IDF soldiers wearing
dresses,
dude? Why were they doing it? Yeah, I think if you had those
takes, you probably just kind of shut the up now.
Honored to be on this list alongside many greats like the Hawk
to a girl. The song was in the Time magazine for their first
ever top 100 creators list. The other political creators include
Diovon, Joe Rogan, and the Hawk to a girl. The Hawker Girls are
a political creator.
What? What? What? Huh?
Awful list. H. It might be an awful list. I heard Asmin Gold
was not on the list, which I literally don't under I don't understand
how you don't have Asmin Gold. How like, isn't that embarrassing
for your list to not have Asmin Gold on the list?
like maybe the single biggest creator right now. It's like sorry,
definitely the biggest political creator right now, right? Almost
certainly.
And then maybe not quite the biggest of all all creators, but
he's probably in like the top five.
Like it's like I show speed, Kaisen, and Asmin Gold. I would
say in the top three.
Aren't those all all those lists pay for play? I don't think
they're all pay for play. You need that the list to have some
kind of legitimacy, right? Dude, this is like well I don't understand
the seething. I just don't get it. I really don't get it at all.
Anyway, what are we doing? We're watching R >> or crying
online as pointed out by Yeet where he says Hassan is a law cow.
No one needs your backing.
That hurts way more at this point than it helps. Also
make >> I don't think it actually hurts more than it helps
at all. Why would people have to um why would people see so much
about this guy if nothing he says matters? sure to thank Night
Media next time. Never seen you give them credit. So, he's crying
about uh the fact that he's a spoiled child of America. >> I
don't know. Hold on. What's the What's the New York Mayor guy?
Zeron Mumani seemed like he benefited from the >> and uh
people are focusing on him. Well, that's the the least I guess
you know what actually the most self-aware communist take I've
seen in a bit. That's the >> Hold on. >> The fact
that he's a spoiled child of
>> and uh people are focusing on him.
>> Well, that's the the least >> No, no, that's not
what that says at all. Is he Is he reading this for the first
time live? Is he reading it at all? He literally didn't read
this. I thought you were pro Israel. I was pro- Israel at the
start of this conflict. I was pro- Israel, but I was like, "Dude,
you have to I was pro- Israel with the caveat, the United States
needs to control Israel because Israel is about to ethnically
cleanse this entire region." That was that was me, okay? I was
the one who said, "Yeah, Israel is not stopping. Israel gets
in there, they're not stopping over this. This is all they needed
right here." So, I support Israel's right to like defend themselves,
to have a country. I generally support Israel, but like I was
like, "Dude, the Palestinians going to need help. gonna need
the US to have oversight over some of this or Israel's going
to go sicko mode. And then Israel went sicko mode, >> I
guess. You know what? Actually, the most self-aware communist
take I've seen in a bit. >> This is crazy. He didn't even
read the tweet at all.
Not even a tiny bit. Not even an attempt to read the tweet. >> And
he also uh celebrates being on Time magazine. And uh you know
there was a there was a German fellow who was on Time magazine
at some point. >> It's I knew Hassan just like guys there
is a German fellow on the cover of Time magazine. It's
it's so Oh wait sorry sorry sorry. Hassan's not on the cover.
Kaisen Kaisen is here. Okay. Kais Kai is
right. Yes. Kaisen. That makes sense. >> I wouldn't be
too happy about that cameo. But anyways, >> dude, this
is
this can't be where Hassan hatred is at. This can't be the people
who are carrying the the banner for Hassan Hatred. Well, actually
was on the cover of Time, so I don't know how happy I'd be about
being on one of their lists.
What? Dude, how about basically anybody's happy to receive an
award, receive a massive accolade in a massive newspaper?
You think Kai's going to sit here and go, "Well, I don't care
about this because was on the cover. This doesn't matter. Was
on the cover." Guys, don't you know this? This actually sucks
for me. Was on the cover of this magazine. They lost without
us. I I feel like that's where it is. >> We have this clip,
too. >> It's very sad. >> Where Hassan compares his
reputation online to the mainstream media and says, "Well, despite
all these fluff pieces, he could do better." >> It's just
fake outrage, though. So, don't I don't know. I need to do more
PR and like by that I mean not PR in like the uh the real media
space because like in mainstream media I have a pretty
uh I I have a a a tremendous number of articles that people write
about me and it's awesome and it's >> Why is he wearing
a hot girls for Zoron shirt? Um because guys who are actually
attractive can wear literally anything and still be attractive
and he's just proving that point. He's subtly mogging you right
now. You think what he wears matters and the whole point of him
wearing that is to show what he wears doesn't matter. That he's
still attractive. Way more attractive than you. You're literally
being mogged by getting upset about it. I hope you know. >> Great.
You know, shouts out the mainstream news. But I need to do PR
in the internet space because there are a lot of like random
content creators who just get all of their information from like
Reddit. So, if you were to just look at Reddit or if you were
to look at just like controversy,
>> listen, we should my people should get in touch with
his people. Okay, >> listen. There's a there's a little
How should we say this? How should we say this? I've got a I've
got a that I am professionally in contact with and he would like
to talk to you, okay? About some mutually beneficial some mutually
beneficial stuff we could talk about. Okay, let's Hassan. Hassan,
give me a call. Give me a call. Huzzan, we've got we got some
people who can actually make good points on your behalf. Okay,
we can do it. Well, just I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I'm kidding. It's a joke. It's a joke. >> Feel like the
way I'm perceived in this uh in the sphere of influencers is
like dramatically different than the way I'm perceived in the
adult politics world. Right. It almost feels like it almost feels
like these are two alternative realities. Now, obviously for
my audience, like mainstream news is way more important, but
it does annoy me sometimes when I have like this um
notion. Did he see these already?
Oh, I haven't seen these yet. the this uh this the idea of like
how I'm perceived by adults who in the political world versus
how I'm perceived by like my immediate peers in the Twitch sphere
that only look at like
uh only associate my content with like drama that other people
are trying to constantly create around me is annoying.
Also, while we're here, let's check in on the the uh Hassan Orbiters
facing the lawsuit from Ethan Klein.
The main component, Denims.
>> Sorry. For some reason, I just felt it would be inappropriate
to miss Denims being on the screen here. Uh totally unrelated
to anything else. All right. Totally unrelated to anything else.
And yeah, totally unrelated. I just wanted to be here for him
commenting on this >> who uh is doing horrible. Do I do
the bit? Do I do the bit chat?
She's raised about a hundred bucks in the last week.
Super chat. Thanks. Uh, super thanks. Whatever it's called, guys,
my enablers. Can we do it again? We did it again two days ago.
Okay,
I won't push it anymore. But anyways, uh, you definitely wanted
to get paid. Also, this seems to be clipped out of a live stream,
right? He's saying chat. So people asking if he just read these
things for the first time. It seems like he was just reading
them for the first time. >> Things are not going well.
She's trying to fight. She >> This just like objectively
worked. By the way, people can laugh at this, but this just objectively
worked. I don't know.
Are we really laughing at her? She won in like every way. >> He's
trying to fight the copyright infringement lawsuit by just like
by her own words.
I won't say it. She's saying it. This is a picture of >> Wait,
he knows that's from the lawsuit, right? He He understands that's
right. There's no possible way he's commenting on this and doesn't
understand that this is from the lawsuit. >> What are we
doing? What are we doing?
I I'm losing my mind, man. It's been a long day.
It's been a long day for
>> She looks like Baby No Money with a wig. Okay. No, you're
wrong. her reasons
I will I will cover tomorrow.
But I'm sorry if I'm a bit uh what's the word? Like uh jumbled
in the brain. Uh there's a lot going on. Okay. And like I said,
we'll cover it tomorrow. Is there big drama with Rev? What's
a lot going on?
Wait, what is he even talking about? A lot going on. Breaking
the people we all knew were terrible are actually much more terrible.
What? What? What? What? What? same girl that got upset, reported
techone and got him banned for calling her the same word. Wait,
no, I think he said and I don't know if you've ever tried taking
like um what' you call it? Not slurs,
but basically like denigrating people with like negative I don't
know, negative words, them doing it to themselves a little different
than you doing it, right? Oh, I'm getting so fat right now versus
oh, you're a fat,
right? Okay.
Oh, I'm going to sled it up today. You're a
obviously different connotations for anybody with like any amount
of brain cell, any amount of brain cells, any amount of brain
power. Obviously, these things are different. I don't know why
people try to say, "Oh, well, I see a little hypocrisy here."
No, it's not hypocrisy at all.
Okay, dude. This Rev guy sucks. That was actually worse than
I thought it would be. Somehow, some way. Hold on. Quick quick
test update. Oh, right. That interview should be out today. The
uh there's the Candace Owens interview, right? Get the Candace
Owens interview. Nick Fentes compares his podcast with Candace
Owens to her Harvey Weinstein
>> There's a setup in that trailer was disgusting. It's
still good to have more eyes on you, but that trailer me the
off and put it behind the pay wall. Maybe if you started acting
more like Weinstein, she would be nicer to you. >> Exa
Exactly. Exactly my point. We're going to exonerate Harvey Weinstein.
We're going to clean up his image. Nick Fuentes, you suck. I
can't I brought you here to tell you that to your face. You suck.
And you you made me mad.
>> Ah, he's got a point. Okay, I hate to agree with this
guy, but he's got a >> Harvey W. Everyone,
please give a warm welcome a Candace show welcome, Harvey Weinstein.
Harvey, everyone says you're right, but I think you know you're
really innocent. You didn't anybody. You just, you know, were
a pervert.
It's like what the
So I got mad because you wouldn't have me on your show and you
know I'm the devil. I'm the most evil person in the world. Harvey
Weinstein,
save this man. Save Harvey.
What? Whatever. I'm not mad, but I'm not mad about it. I'm not
mad. I'm not mad about this at all.
Are Fenta's anties actually on average or um I mean it's not
to hate Nick or hate his political opinions, but a lot of the
people who do hate him do so mindlessly. Sure, there would be
a lot more to hate Nick Fuentes because people who aren't as
tell them they should hate Nick Fuentes. That's almost certainly
true, right? Wait, OMFG, he's pro. The interview isn't out, is
it? There's no way. It's Thursday today. Yeah, the interview
isn't out. There's only a trailer
and then apparently it's behind a payw wall. I'll watch it, but
I do want to I do want to see.